Die letzten 82 Folgen haben uns alle wahnsinnig gelangweilt und ich bin ja auch schon mal weggenickt. Ich möchte den Jungs da überhaupt keinen Vorwurf machen. Ich sage das seit langen Jahren, dass unser Podcast-Betrieb völlig aufgebauscht ist und aufgebauscht wird und das scheint kein Ende zu nehmen. Und die Spitzenpodcaster, von denen wir hoffen, dass sie top Leistungen bringen, die sind für mich völlig überlastet und aus diesem Grunde glaube ich auch, dass sie eben auch nicht ihre top Leistungen abrufen können. Die werden sich jetzt vielleicht mal wieder in den entsprechenden Folgen hochpushen. Das macht ja sein. Dann werden sich die Hörer anschließend wieder freuen können. Die haben jetzt keinen Urlaub, die haben keine vernünftige Vorbereitung und sind dann voll im Podcast wieder drin. Das kann man sehen, wo Podcastler da landen, wenn ich ihn gucke, ist der 31. Der hat gefühlt die Karriere eines 37-Jährigen hinter sich. Jede zweite Woche. Diese Leute können sich fast nie wieder regenerieren und erholen. Ich halte das für sehr, sehr gefährlich. Das Entscheidende ist, dass Leute Spaß an den Podcasts haben. Aber ich glaube, dass wir unser Produkt seit langen Jahren immer mehr verwässern. Weil es eben nicht geht, dass du 4 Stunden wieder auf hohem Niveau sein kannst und noch mal, noch mal, noch mal, wenn ich mich in den Podcasten versetzen würde, ich wäre froh, wenn ich nach Hause gehen könnte, wenn ich mal Urlaub machen dürfte. Ich hätte gar keinen Bock da zu sein, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Den Jungs wird so viel abverlangt und am Ende des Tages ist es auch ein Podcast, was Spaß machen soll und Spaß machen muss. Es ist zwar auch harte Arbeit, aber ich muss auch frei im Kopf sein, ich muss frisch sein, ich muss richtig Lust haben. Und die Jungs werden immer und immer und immer wieder ins Feuer geschickt. Ich glaube nicht, dass ihr euch hier eine Vorstellung davon machen könnt, was das bedeutet.
Gut, soviel zum Thema Weltraum. Wollen wir über Sport reden?
Ich war ein bisschen shoppen. Da ich ja irgendwann doch angefangen habe zu laufen, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, obwohl ich dachte, laufen wäre nie so meins, habe ich mir natürlich gedacht, da brauche ich auch noch eine Uhr dafür. Ziehe mir schön die Wegstrecke auf. Dafür habe ich nicht das passende Problem, tut mir leid.
Ich wollte nur ein bisschen rumgiften.
Apple-Geräte, für die hat man nicht das Problem. Für die hat man einfach die Lust, sie zu kaufen.
Da fehlt mir die Lust, das Ding zu haben. Na gut. Mir sind halt mehrere Sachen aufgefallen. Ich wollte einen GPS-Tracker schon länger haben, fürs Wandern eigentlich. Aber so ein reiner GPS-Tracker ist echt ganz schön teuer. Da dachte ich mir so, ach nee, dann kaufst du dir das halt nicht. Mit dem Laufen dachte man sich so, vielleicht wäre es irgendwie ganz nett, die Strecke, die man läuft, aufzunehmen. Und auch so zu sehen.
Wofür eigentlich?
Dass ich Sport mache?
Also ich bin ja Motorradfahrer und da gibt es auch, da kann man sich halt seine Strecken aufzeichnen lassen. Habe ich einmal gemacht, weil ich wissen wollte, ob es geht. Aber ja, man braucht das für nix, diese Strecke danach.
Beim Laufen will ich einfach nur wissen, wie viel Kilometer, aber beim Wandern nicht. Beim Wandern nehme ich zwar meistens die Strecke, die vorgegeben ist, oder was die Beschilderung während der Trails sagt. Aber wenn du dann doch mal links und rechts davon dich bewegst, finde ich das schon ganz cool, wenn man in größeren Strecken läuft, das auch noch mal nachzuverfolgen.
Das geht ja dann auch in Kombination mit so etwas wie Pulsmessung, dass du danach auch sehen kannst, welcher Teil der Strecke hat dich wie sehr belastet.
Also beim Wandern weiß ich noch nicht, ob ich, also ich habe keinen Pulsmesser über die Uhr drin, ich habe einen Herzfrequenz-Sensor, einen Brustgurt. Eine Polar M400. Ne, es ist die billige Variante, die ich aufgrund der wirklich sehr schönen Farbe für 120 Euro geschossen habe. So ein Normalpress ist glaube ich mit Brustgurt zwischen 140-150 bis 200 hoch.
Weil die Farbe so schön war, durftest du weniger bezahlen?
Keine Ahnung. Es ist mir auch bei den iPhones aber schon einige Male aufgefallen, dass diese hässlichen Gold, wie ich jetzt eins Gold habe, und Rose Gold meistens günstiger sind. Ja, aber ich gucke da hinten eh nicht drauf.
Was?
Aber nicht im Wiederverkauf.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht.
Wenn man sich auf so verschiedenen Preisvergleichsportalen geschaut hat, waren die halt meistens günstiger. Ich weiß nicht warum. Jedenfalls bei dieser Uhr war es der Fall, dass einige relativ günstig waren. Und da ich Freunde habe, die sich auch so auf Marathon mit solchen Uhren vorbereiten, dachte ich mir so, ok, kaufen wir mal eine Polaruhr.
Kein Raum mehr für Interpretationen.
Das ist pink, das sieht für mich eher aus wie...
Schweinchenrosa, können wir es auch. Also so eine Mischung aus Pink und Schweinchenrosa.
Schweinchenrosa trifft es auch nicht so richtig.
Ist mir auch manchmal schon ein bisschen unangenehm, ich hab jetzt auch so pinkische Laufschuhe und ne pinkische Leggings. Und in der Tat sogar noch ein pinkes Shirt. Nee, keine Angst. Mädchen, hihihi.
Wo du doch sonst immer so stilsicher gekleidet bist.
Ach, deswegen, ist auch die Gesellschaft.
Wo du doch sonst immer so stilsicher gekleidet bist, Letty.
Ja, das ist richtig, weil ich sonst nur Schwarz trage. Aber Leggings in der Tat dürfen bei mir sehr bunt sein. Nicht nur zum Laufen, dafür hab ich sie eigentlich nicht gekauft. Und Schuhe finde ich in der Tat, so Sportschuhe, so relativ schrille schon geil. Das fand ich im Laden auch natürlich super. Also ich meinte so, ja Farbe, so schrille wie es geht. Mach mal die Uhr bitte. Also die hat irgendwie super viele Funktionen, mit der sie irgendwie daherkommt. Dass du dich wirklich auf den Marathon mit den Uhren vorbereiten kannst. Dass die dir so einen Trainingsplan auch vorgeben. Aber derzeit, ich nutze die eigentlich nur, um die Strecken aufzuzeichnen, Herzfrequenz mir anzuschauen, gerade so auch so ein bisschen die Strecke zu analysieren, wo bin ich langsam gelaufen. Dann weiß ich manchmal ja auch, wenn ich drauf gucke, ah ok, Straße überquert.
Und Puls misst das Ding nicht, deswegen hast du diesen Brustgurt.
Ja, warum ist ja nicht einfach der Pulsmesser noch direkt in der Uhr?
Was kostet der Brustgurt extra?
Ich glaube bei denen direkt 60. Du kannst aber jeden nehmen. Bluetooth oder ist das irgendwie? Du kannst halt auch jeden X-Beliebigen nehmen, außer die von Garmin glaube ich. Die haben irgendeinen Sonderfufeil, wie die sich kopplen.
Gibt es auch iPhones für Android oder iPhone oder so, dass man die auch mit was anderem auslesen kann?
Die Daten kannst du dir komplett runterladen bei dem Portal.
Nehmen wir dann der Gurt.
Das habe ich mich schon gefragt, das will ich mal ausprobieren. Theoretisch müsste das doch mit der Batch gehen, oder? Mit der Radio-Batch? Aber, weiß ich nicht, müsste man mal gucken. Das würde mich interessieren, weil uns ist nämlich so ein bisschen die Frage aufgekommen, wenn es schon so nah ist, so am Körper, ob man nicht auch sogar die Atemzüge damit noch auslesen könnte. Was ja dann relativ interessant wird, wenn du das vergleichst dann auch noch. Wie deine Atmung so ist. Ja, also eine Freundin meinte, dass das sehr, sehr... Also wenn man eh schon die Herzfrequenz und das alles hatten, dass ja auch sehr nah am Brustgut, logischerweise auch an der Lunge sitzt, sollte man das hinbekommen.
Ich hätte noch so eine Tankanzeige dabei, die mir sagt, wie viele Kilometer ich jetzt noch laufen kann.
Das gibt es außerdem, dass du dir so die Tankanzeige sofort definierst. Oder aber der nächste Späti kommt dann so und so viele Meter an. Du kannst dir das nächste Bier schnappen. In der Tat habe ich heute gelesen, dass es diese Uhr, also ebenso diese GPS-Funktion hat. Und wenn du dich ein bisschen so in deinem Hood verlaufen hast beim Laufen, gibt es wohl eine Funktion, die dich zu deinem Startpunkt zurückbringt. Und die will ich unbedingt ausprobieren. Das finde ich interessant.
Aha, wie denn?
Also, das ist eine gute Frage. Das wird sicherlich die GPS-Sachen dahinter nutzen, die es auch abgespeichert hat.
Ja, aber sich im Prenzlauer Berg zu verlaufen, ist jetzt eher schwierig, oder?
Nee, aber ich will die Uhr nach Quito zum Beispiel mitnehmen, wenn ich in Quito bin und in Quito laufen. Ich meine, 2800 Höhenmeter muss man mal ausprobiert haben beim Laufen.
Die läufst ja nicht hoch, du bist ja schon oben hin.
Ja, trotzdem. Das musst du erstmal ausprobieren, da oben zu laufen.
Ja, ist die Luft ein bisschen dünner, aber das passt sich anders, das machen alle Sportler.
Ja, aber kommt natürlich auch an, ob es feucht ist oder so. Aber, ich mein...
Und wie ist die Usability? Ich meine, ich hab ja jetzt auch gerade mit WatchOS 3 teste ich jetzt auch gerade mal wieder so alles durch, wie sich die Uhr so als Sportpartner bewährt.
Das ist aber jetzt noch die alte Series Null, ne?
Genau.
Series Null, genau.
So wird die jetzt genannt.
Das ist nicht die schlechteste Bezeichnung dafür.
Also ich benutze einfach die eingebaute whatever und bin damit für meine Zwecke gut genug.
Ich laufe halt nicht mit.
Du machst halt kein GPS-Tracking, oder?
Na, mach das Phone. Und das macht's gut genug.
Das Phone macht das?
Ja, natürlich.
Wo, wie, was? Wo, wie, wo?
Der Phone hat ja GPS. Also du musst es halt mit haben.
Ich hab's ja immer mit.
Mit der neun Uhr muss man's ja nicht mehr mit haben.
Na, wenn du, wenn du... Ach Gottchen, wie heißt das? Diese Sports... Diese komischen Sportdingens, dieses...
Aktivität.
Aktivität, genau. Da drückst du drauf. Bei mir ist das ja immer Rad Outdoor.
Ja.
Dann drück ich da drauf, dann zählt da 3, 2, 1 und dann geht's los.
Ja, aber wo ist die Karte? Ah, hier.
Die Karte ist Christe hinterher, in dem... Stimmt.... in diesem Aktivitäts-Dings unten kriegst du dann die rote. Bei mir hat das jetzt 3 Tage nicht funktioniert, weil ich irgendwie schlauerweise die nächste Beta-Version auf die Spur Uhr gespielt habe, aber die nicht auf dem Phone hatte. Aber... Also für meine Zwecke ist das gut genug.
und korreliert der dann auch? der korreliert dann nicht den Puls, oder? Davon sehe ich jetzt hier nichts.
Das kann sein, dass es nicht tut, ja.
Ja, weil das ist ja so, sagen wir mal, das eigentliche Feature. Also wo ich lang gelaufen bin, das weiß ich ja im Zweifelsfall noch selber. Aber man will ja auch wissen, wie gut es einem ging. So. Aber warte mal, das ist doch jetzt echt interessant. Na ja, schon, klar. Weil ich meine, über die Belastung kannst du ja deine Aussage über deinen Trainingszustand fällen.
Ich weiß nicht, kann ich... Tim, kann ich hier auf dem Monitor was scheren? Ich meine, dann kann ich euch mal die Trainingsanzeige auch zeigen. Also von so einem Trainings-Run.
Luftspiel einschalten.
Ich überleg grad, wo es war.
Ja, leider treten die Apple-Aktivitäten nicht in Rantestik auf. Aber Brustgurt, mal echt.
Bin ich jetzt gerade im falschen Netz? Ich sehe deinen Airplay nicht.
Wahrscheinlich.
Was?
Die Weiß. Willst du jetzt nicht das Passwort durch den... Achso, du kannst doch einfach Kabel reinstecken. Weißt du auch, hier Ethernet und so.
Hier ist doch, hier ist doch, hier bist du auch bestimmt.
Aber das WLAN-Passwort ist doch da oben oder nicht?
Haben wir auch einen Adapter?
Nee, das ist für Public.
Ist das nicht das gleiche?
Da muss ich wohl mal kurz hier bei mir aussteppen.
Nee, ich hab ja noch mehr Adapter. So ist es ja nicht.
Du kannst ja den mal nehmen, während Tim versucht neue Adapter zu finden.
Du kannst ja nicht das Passwort kurz im Chat mal rüber schieben, ne?
Technik.
Die begeistert.
Wahrscheinlich wird mir gleich vor Freude auch der Rechner wieder abstürzen, wenn ich hier auf das Airplay zugreifen will.
Ich danke dir.
Funktioniert ja auch alles besser über iEDaNet, weißt du auch, wie das ist.
Meister EDaNet.
So, dann mal her mit dem Luftspiel. Ich muss eh nochmal testen, ob das funktioniert. Ich hab hier gerade meinen Apple TV ausgetauscht.
Hast du jetzt einen aktuellen Apple TV?
Nee, jetzt hab ich den aktuellen bei mir in die Wohnung reingetan, weil...
Können wir Fenster ein bisschen ranmachen, das zieht so kalt hier unten durch irgendwie.
Ja, komischerweise hab ich immer noch keine Airplay-Option.
Kannst du das auch einfach beschreiben, die Hörer können es ja sowieso nicht sehen.
Ich halte es halt einfach falsch. Können wir ein Screenshot davon machen. Nee, aber es ist irgendwie ganz nett, so die Herzfrequenz zu sehen, in welchem Herzfrequenz-Bereich man so unterwegs ist und wie sich halt auch so, also ich laufe jetzt irgendwie erst einen Monat, aber wie sich das halt schon so ein bisschen konstanter alles einpegelt nach einer Zeit. Das ist irgendwie ganz nett. Ja, und ich laufe halt nicht mit Telefon, also ich hab maximal die Uhr und den Schlüssel dabei und das war's. Mehr würde ich mit mir halt auch nicht rumschleppen müssen.
Ist mir das schonmal hier, dass man ja auch hier mit dem Phone, mit der Flitzlampe und der Kamera seinen Puls messen kann?
Ja, aber nicht mit Bordmitteln, da brauchst du dann zusätzliche Anbieter.
Da brauchst du dann noch eine App für, ja.
Ja, das funktioniert aber auch noch.
83, uiuiuiui.
Woll ich, man könnte ja mal hier Vergleichsmessungen machen.
Achso, du hältst jetzt einfach deinen Finger hinten auf die LED.
Auf die LED, die Kamera nimmt auf und nimmt den Farbunterschied im Rot, weil mehr, weil das Blut ja immer so in den Zügen kommt, im Puls halt. Ich hab hier diese Health Mate, die von dieser Withings Companies, wo ich meine Waage von habe.
Ah, Gesundheitsmarte.
Das fehlt noch im Angebot der süßen, koffeinhaltigen Getränke, die Gesundheitsmarte.
Also ich verstehe das mit dem Brustgurt nicht. Man kann auch irgendwie den Puls auch wunderbar...
Die Genauigkeit ist aber nicht dieselbe. Dazu gibt es sogar wissenschaftliche Paper. Nee, das habe ich letztens aber darauf verwiesen gesehen. Also ich meine, warum soll ich mir eine Uhr kaufen, die niemand meiner ernsthaften Sportfreunde nutzt, also die wirklich ernsthaft damit trainieren? Ich kaufe mir keine Fashion-Uhr. Nee, für die Läufer, die wirklich Marathon und alles laufen, die laufen definitiv mit Uhr. Damit du halt weißt, wann du wieder deine...
Du hast ja auch Pace-Maker, damit man nicht zu schnell ist und nicht zu langsam und so.
Auch als normaler Läufer. Du hast immer deine Uhr dabei, damit du eben genau weißt, wann gehst du runter mit der Geschwindigkeit, damit sich dein Puls noch ein bisschen wieder in den Herz weckt, wenn es ein bisschen runtergeht.
Das meine ich ja mit Pace-Maker, also dass die Uhr den Speed vorgibt, damit man genau weiß, jetzt nicht zu schnell, nicht zu langsam.
Kannst du bei der machen.
Die brauchen doch so beim Marathon auch, dass sie nicht vor Ausgaben schon am Anfang und das kann man ja manchmal schwer einschätzen.
Genau, das kannst du mit der alles machen. Also das habe ich noch nicht alles ausprobiert, ein paar Sachen schon, aber irgendwie hier mir einzubilden, dass ich irgendwie in diesen nicht in den höchsten Herzfrequenzbereich reingehe. Dann kannst du das halt piepen lassen, wenn du in diesen Bereich reinkommst. Also hat das dann ständig gepiept und das willst du dann auch nicht haben. Da war ich halt einfach noch nicht gut trainiert genug dafür. Aber es ist irgendwie ganz nett und was mir aber aufgefallen ist, also ich trage halt eh keine Uhren und ich habe direkt erst mal eine Abdruckstelle davon bekommen. Also die geht auch nicht so richtig weg gerade. Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe hier so ein paar Druckstellen.
Hornhaut an der Hand Innenseite.
Hornhaut habe ich nur auf den Fingern vom Klettern.
Also du würdest das auf jeden Fall empfehlen.
Ja, ich finde das spannend. Hier wurde auch gerade schon im Chat geschrieben, dass man über die Android-App wohl ganz viele der Daten sehen kann, die wirklich rauskommen, weil mehr als nur die Herzfrequenz wohl rausfällt. Ah, und da gibt es auch noch eins für den App Store. Wunderbar. Na das muss ich mir mal anschauen. Also ich find's sehr spannend auf jeden Fall. Ich hab's auch mal versucht so wirklich als Activity Logger so den ganzen Tag das Ding zu tragen und oh Gott, ich mag Uhren nicht. Das war noch nie so mein Device und...
Aber du hast sie ja eh um.
Nee, die hab ich zum Laufen nur um. Ja, aber für mehr will ich sie nicht tragen. Also dann merk ich einfach, dass das atmet weh und ich stoß da auch ständig irgendwo ran. Also wahrscheinlich würde meine mehr beim Apple Support liegen, damit sie ständig repariert wird.
Mich musst du erstmal schlagen.
Ja, das stimmt, das ist richtig.
Das ist ja jetzt auch schon die dritte.
Apollo 3.
Apollo 3?
Nein, kann man ja hochzählen, solange bis es dann mal klappt, quasi.
Hatt ich eigentlich in der letzten Sendung mein iPhone, da war es gerade eingeschickt, ne?
Du hattest da irgendwie einen anderes, so lang oder wie war das?
Genau.
Und jetzt hast du schon wieder, oder?
Ich hab mein iPhone SE wieder. Und? Es ist bemerkenswert zu sehen, was so 5, 5, 5, 5S, 6, 6S, 3 Generationen iPhone so ausmachen.
Achso zwischen dem 5 und dem 5 SE?
Ja, also das ist mit der App, was du meinst. Ja, man kann auf so einem iPhone 5 einfach, da kannst du schon gar nicht mehr mit arbeiten. Also zwar so vom User Interface geht das gerade irgendwie so noch, aber so dieser Speicherhunger der Apps, der ist so dermaßen angewachsen, dass einfach die Chance, dass das Programm schon wieder gekillt ist, wenn du es nur einmal in der Woche legst, so hoch ist, dass du irgendwie gar nicht mehr mit arbeiten kannst und so bestimmte richtig schlecht programmierte Apps kommen irgendwie auch gar nicht mehr hoch.
Hast du da ein iOS 10 draufgemacht?
Ich habe da ein iOS 10 draufgemacht, ja.
Das ist natürlich auch sportlich, aber ja, warum?
Ich habe halt aus dem Backup, was sollte ich tun?
Nein, nein, das ist ja nur trotzdem sportlich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es sportlich. Man könnte ja auch mal sein, dass diese neuen iOS ein bisschen schneller sind. Ich fand das jetzt vom iOS her eigentlich auch okay, aber es war halt von den Apps eigentlich eher total schwer, aber jetzt bin ich wieder ein Happy SE User und finde es super.
Ich finde es macht ein bisschen Sehenscheiden, die Entzündung des iPhones.
Das kann ich ja nicht verstehen. Wovon redest du?
Ich auch nicht.
Ich habe das iPhone irgendwie mal zwei Tage benutzt und habe versucht, auf mein Schnittchen zu verzichten. Und ich habe vom Halten.
Schnittchen?
Das ist Blackberry. Es hat halt einen Namen.
Haben deine Geräte einen Namen?
Schnittchen hat einen Namen, ja. Geräte, die ich liebe, schon.
Dein iPhone heißt einfach nur iPhone, oder wie?
So heißt dein iPhone?
Gut, also noch was nachzutragen zum Thema Sport?
Nein, würde ich jetzt nicht so sagen. Mich würde interessieren auch mal, was ich testen würde, ist die Uhr. Vielleicht würde ich sie mal zum Klettern mitnehmen wollen, um da so ein bisschen zu checken, was ich so für Herzfrequenzen beim Klettern habe. Das würde mich mal interessieren, aber die ist ja wahnsinnig im Weg. Da kann man sie nicht tragen, muss man sie irgendwo festmachen. Ich hab's beim Yoga gemerkt.
Ja, beim Klettern, wenn du das am Handklenk hast, vor allem wenn du auch dann irgendwo hängen bleibst.
Ja, genau. Selbst beim Yoga nervt es schon ohne Ende.
Beim Yoga?
Ja.
Du trägst die Polaruhr beim Yoga.
Wenn ich mich dehne vor dem Laufen, so dehne, ein bisschen Yoga machen.
Dann misst es auch noch deine Dehnung?
Nee, dann misse ich noch. Wie weit man im Spagat sitzen kann und überhaupt. Nee, ich hab's halt einfach, trage ich sie dann meistens im Brustgurz, um zu sehen, wie so die Herzfrequenz einfach ist. Also es ist gerade einfach nur spannend, so Kurven zu verfolgen.
Du bist einfach kurvengeil. Ich bin kurvengeil. Du bist ja so eine Chart-Lady irgendwie. Du nimmst ja diese Rohdaten dann auch und visualisierst sie mal selber ein bisschen?
Ich bin so ein bisschen geneigt, das auch mal zu machen. Auch gerade so vielleicht mal die Daten zu analysieren, wenn man so mal wirklich so ein Jahr gelaufen ist. Ich würde mich echt interessieren, die Daten mal zu analysieren, ob man so Muster erkennt in den Daten, die man so vom Laufen her hat. Ob das auch auf die Strecke zurückzuführen ist, oder ob du aber immer sagen kannst, bei Kilometer 5, da bricht sie jedes Mal aus Neue ein. Also das würde mich mal interessieren, ob du so Daten sehen kannst.
Ja, mach mal.
Aber wie gesagt, da muss ich erstmal ein bisschen laufen und dran bleiben.
Erstmal ein paar Daten generieren.
Erstmal ein paar Daten generieren und visualisieren, ja. Und was halt auch, also beim Wandern auf jeden Fall will ich das nächstes Jahr ausprobieren. Wie sie sich da schlägt auch von der Akkulaufzeit. Also ich hab's jetzt noch nicht wieder geladen. Ich hab sie seit dem 9. September jetzt, glaube ich, also 20 Tage fast in Gebrauch und hab sie noch nicht wieder geladen. Ist erstmal schon mal ganz cool, dass sie scheinbar eine gute Akkulaufzeit hat. Also gerade wenn du beim Wandern unterwegs bist und irgendwie neun Stunden, du läufst keine neun Stunden. Aber so bis zu sieben läuft man ja doch manchmal. Das würde mich mal interessieren, wie sie dann...
Ja, vor allem wenn sie dauerhaft GPS macht.
Genau, wenn sie dauerhaft GPS macht.
Also da bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher, ob das so sehr viel schlechter ist als bei der Apple Watch.
Naja, ich hab ja bei meinen Telefonen auch immer auf Flugmodus, wenn ich laufe. Also ich will halt nicht die ganzen Scheiße um mich haben. Also ganze Notification hier und da.
Weil du ja eigentlich im Tiefflug unterwegs bist.
Ich bin einfach genau im Tiefflug unterwegs.
Für ein iPhone reicht es noch nicht, aber du bist ausreichend in der Lage, dir so einen Schub zu geben, dass du dir irgendwie geile Gadgets für Sport kaufst. Du machst sogar Sportarten, von denen du eigentlich dachtest, dass du sie nicht machen würdest.
Ja, Laufen definitiv.
Ja, ist auch gar nicht so schlecht, Laufen.
Ich hab gerade ein bisschen Knieschmerzen, aber man wird halt älter. Nee, aber Laufen macht grad Spaß. Und man muss sich an keine soziale Gruppe binden, um sich zu motivieren.
Das ist allerdings ein Riesenpunkt.
Und Timme, am Samstag war ja hier Inlineskatermarathon oder sowas, ne? Ah ja. Warst du auch nicht dabei, ne?
Nee, war ich nicht dabei.
Das wär aber mal interessant.
Ich war mal dabei, also ich bin schon mehrere Male Inlineskatermarathon gelaufen. Ich glaub insgesamt drei oder vier Mal. Aber das letzte Mal schon eine Weile her.
Ist eigentlich der Skatermarathon auch nur die 42 Kilometer?
Ja. Exakt die gleiche Strecke, ja? In Berlin ist es nicht exakt dieselbe Strecke, sondern es sind so zwei, drei Straßenführungen anders. Wegen Skaterbedarf. Wegen des Bodens vermutlich. Also der Bodenbelagsqualität. Aber ansonsten ist die Distanz natürlich dieselbe. Und für Skaten ist es eine geile Distanz. 42 Kilometer ist echt super. Ich hab das auch gerne gemacht. Ich hab das auch ganz gut hinbekommen seiner Zeit. Ich glaub, meine beste Zeit war 1,35. Das ist jetzt nicht außergewöhnlich. Aber jetzt ordentlich muss man sich jetzt nicht verschämen. Das würde ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht nochmal erreichen. Außerdem hab ich neulich beim Umzug festgestellt, dass meine Inline-Skates weg sind.
Ich hab gesehen, dass die ja ihre Rollen alle umgestellt haben. Also früher waren ja anscheinend vier Rollen angesagt. Jetzt fahren die alle auf drei Rollen und die sind viel größer. Die sehen ja Reibungen und so und durch die größeren Rollen bessere Rolleigenschaften.
Ja, ich hatte ja noch einen Fünfer.
Fünfer, das ist gar nicht mehr angesagt. Fünfer hab ich gar nicht gesehen, glaub ich. Die vorne hatten alle Dreier die Profis und hinten kamen dann immer mehr Vierer und ganz am Ende waren nur noch Vierer.
Ja, kann schon sein. Ich find aber die Fünfer sehen geiler aus.
Ja, aber die Rollen sind zu klein, das ist nicht so gut.
Na, du hast ja dann immer ein Platzproblem, musstest ja auch noch unter Fuß kriegen.
Aber Vierer habe ich auf jeden Fall in Großaschang gesehen.
Das war dann der erste Trend. Also erst gab's die Vierer normal, dann gab's die Fünfer für die Skater, die halt einfach längere Kufe brauchten, haben sie halt einfach noch eine Rolle dazugenommen. Und dann kamen sie mit den großen Viererrollen. Und der Trend zu Dreier, wobei Dreier muss ich sagen, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir einen Dreier holen würde, dann schon eher große Vierer. Weil klar, weniger Reibung, kann ich alles verstehen, super. Aber das heißt halt, du hast auch noch weniger Führung nach vorne. Also dieser weniger Bodenkontakt bedeutet ja auch, dass du sozusagen weniger Spurführung hast.
Weniger Bodenkontakt oder weil sozusagen deine, die Länge vom ersten Rad bis zum letzten kürzer ist?
Die ist nicht unbedingt kürzer, weil die Rollen sind ja größer. Aber du hast halt weniger Kontaktpunkte. Das heißt, du hast dann eben auch weniger Bodenhaftung. Und ich hätte so ein bisschen Bedenken, dass man da schneller los eiert. Aber da kann ich mich nicht wirklich so zu äußern. Das scheint ja offensichtlich trotzdem zu funktionieren, wenn so viele Leute das benutzen.
Wie gesagt, umso größer die Rollen sind, umso besser rollt sich das ab. Eigentlich sollte man, das gibt es ja irgendwie so Tests bei Autos, eigentlich müsste man da auch viel größere Reifen nehmen und dafür schmaler, weil das rollt besser ab und verbraucht viel weniger Energie. Also jedes kleinste Millimeter Hindernis muss ja überrollt werden. Und umso größer dein Reifen ist, umso besser rollt er da drüber. Mag natürlich bei einem Millimeter nicht so wichtig aussehen, aber am Ende kommt da halt schon was zusammen, was da an Rollwiderstand zusammenkommt. Deswegen auch so Geländemotorräder zum Beispiel, haben einfach sehr große Räder. Und so Sportmotorräder sind eher kleiner, wegen auch Gewicht und so natürlich.
Ich fand, dass meine 5er-Rollen einfach geil aussahen. Ich bin sehr traurig, dass ich die nicht mehr habe. Ich hab auch keine Ahnung, wo sie sind.
Die waren einfach weg. Du hast ja super Ausrede, um jetzt 3er-Rolle zu holen. Oder zumindest mal Probe zu fahren. Kannst dir live berichten.
Na mal gucken, ich bring mich jetzt gerade erst mal wieder lauftechnisch erst mal wieder in Shape. Und wenn ich das schaffe, bis zum nächsten Sommer, das durchzuhalten und ich fit bin, wie ein Tonschuhe auf dem Weg zum Mars, dann würde ich das auch mal wieder erwägen. Weil man soll ja nicht immer so dieses Marathon, das ist auch so ein bisschen gefährlich. Gerade umso älter man wird, ist halt immer so dieser, das schaffe ich noch! Ich bin noch nicht so alt! Kein Problem! Dann bist du dann so eine Randnotiz in der Zeitung so. Ah, wieder einer umgekippt. Sorry.
Wieso gibt es da nicht auch den, wie heißen sie doch gleich, die Busse, die hinterherfahren, auch bei den Skates?
Klumpensammler.
Na ja gut, aber was hilft mir, wenn ich da irgendwie meine Herzattacke kriege?
Ach komm, so schlimm wird es ja wohl nicht sein.
Bei mir? Das denken die anderen auch alle. Tja, so läuft das. Ein Skater ist auch noch bei einem Haufen gefahren.
Jetzt am Wochenende?
Ich bin mir gerade nicht so sicher, ob es hier in Berlin war. Ich glaube doch, da war irgendwas.
Was ist denn deine Distanz gerade beim Laufen?
Oh, wenig. Ich muss mich erstmal wieder ranführen.
Oder was ist denn dein Ziel?
Ich will wieder auf 10 kommen und jetzt bin ich bei 5. Aber es lief schon besser letztes Mal. Ich bin dran.
Guckst du auch auf deinen Tempo?
Ich will einen 6-Minuten-Pace auf jeden Fall halten. Ich will sozusagen die 10 Kilometer in einer Stunde. Das ist jetzt nicht außerordentlich schnell, aber das muss ich schon ein bisschen bewegen. Nicht so hoch ansetzen, so könnte das funktionieren. So hatte ich das auch schon mal, so mache ich das wieder. Und dann kann ich immer noch größer wahnsinnig werden und Marathons laufen wollen oder was weiß ich. Aber ich glaube, so Laufmarathon, das mache ich auf gar keinen Fall. Skatermarathon, mal gucken. Aber dann brauche ich auch einen guten Laufbody. Weil während Laufen, also so normales Laufen, hast du recht, ist geil, weil man da einfach so wunderbar allein sein kann. Aber Skaten macht irgendwie mehr Bock mit Leuten zusammen. Also vielleicht bin ich da falsch sozialisiert, weil ich irgendwie, ich habe mal diese Wahnsinns-Tour da gemacht, habe ich gleich schon erzählt. Ich bin ja mal so von Freiburg nach Hamburg gelaufen. In zwei Wochen. Und dann waren wir halt so eine Truppe von irgendwie 15 Wahnsinnigen und sind halt immer schön Kette gefahren und haben dann so einen Windschatten, einer vorne, die alle anderen so hinten dran mit festhalten. Genau. Das ist so irre. Also das hat so gebockt. Weil klar, das hat den Duftwiderstand von einem, aber halt die Power von 15. Und wir sind da wie so eine Maschine irgendwie so durch dieses Land gelaufen. Mit irgendwie teilweise 60 Sachen. Das rockt schon so richtig. Und dann vor allem allein dieser Sound, den du dann irgendwie hast. War immer ganz lustig. In Städten kam dann irgendwie die Polizei und wollte uns irgendwie erst so ein bisschen führen und so. Und dann haben die gesehen, wie wir da abgegangen sind. Dann sind sie uns irgendwie gleich so mit dem Motorrad vorweg und haben angefangen, die Ampeln auf vorzuschalten.
Hat das du glaubst schon mal erzählt?
Spaßige Zeit, ja, ich bestimmt schon mal erzählt. Ich wiederhole mich ja laufend. Aber wie auch immer, das Skatereis an sich ist eine schöne Sache, aber man muss halt auch aufpassen. Ich hab mich schon mal nach einer Pause mir gedacht, ich bin schon der Coolste und das schaffe ich schon. Und dann lag ich da halt, bumm, und dann hat ich erst mal gebrochenes Handgelenk und viel Spaß.
Und immer schön dehnen vorm Sport.
Immer schön dehnen vorm Sport. So ist aber Schluss mit Sport hier. Los Dennis, jetzt reden wir mal wieder über...
Pokémon.
Über Pokémon Go. Dennis spielt übrigens hier die ganze Zeit Pokémon Go.
Zu seiner Verteidigung nicht nur er.
Ach so, du auch?
Er hat mich ja jetzt infiziert, ja ja.
Na das Schöne ist hier, dass wir hier bei dir genau zwischen zwei Pokestops sitzen. Das heißt, ich kann ja alle 5 Minuten 100 Punkte machen. Und in 4 Stunden kriegt man schon irgendwie ein paar Punkte zusammen, 4800. Auf die so perfekt redet man nicht, aber... Nee, da kann man nicht viel zu erzählen.
Ja, ich wollte auch gar nicht dich auf Pokémon Go ansprechen, sondern ich wollte, dass du mal deine Kompressionserfahrung unter das Volk bringst.
Sehr schön. Also, ich bin ja... Können wir gleich beide Thema hintereinander irgendwie. Die hören ja so, kann ich gut zusammenkleben. Also, fangen wir beide mit Z an. Ihr wisst ja schon, was jetzt kommt. Also, was danach kommt. Also, jetzt erstmal Compression. Gibt's einen neuen Kompressionsalgorithmus von dem gleichen Typen.
Also, wir reden von Datenkompression, nicht von Audio oder Video.
Es gibt ja lossy-Kompression, so Audio, also MPEG und AAC. Also, wenn es nicht lossless ist, dann ist das alles lossy. Und dann gibt's natürlich so wie G-Zip und wie heißt das alles hier? B-Zip, LZMA und Deflate nennt man's auch noch und so weiter. Das ist alles lossless-Kompression. Ja, genau, man kriegt exakt das wieder raus, was man braucht. Es ist besonders gut, wenn man Programme komprimiert oder Daten, die einem wichtig sind. Jedenfalls haben wir, glaube ich, vor zwei, drei Jahren schon mal was vorgestellt, LZ4 von so einem Franzosen. Und der war zwar super, super schnell, also schneller als wirklich alles andere, aber hat auch nur so, naja, die Komprimierungsrate war ein bisschen schlechter als G-Zip. Aber die Geschwindigkeit war es ja auch, wenn man nicht viel Zeit hat zum Beispiel, bei bestimmten Sachen ist das ja so, dann war der ganz gut. Aber wenn man halt besser komprimieren wollte, hat man G-Zip oder B-Zip oder LZMA, wie sie alle heißen. Jedenfalls der gleiche Typ hat jetzt irgendwie wieder zwei Jahre lang an seinem Kämmerchen gearbeitet. Der hat auch einen schicken Blogpost, wo man das immer so verfolgen kann. Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich den jetzt schnell finde. Und dort hat er jetzt einen neuen Kompressionsalgorithmus vorgestellt, den hat er genannt Z-Standard. Da geht es nicht wieder darum, möglichst eine hohe Kompressionsrate zu haben. Da gibt es irgendwie ganz andere. Da gibt es halt diesen LZ-MA zum Beispiel. Oder wie heißt der?
Keine Ahnung, BZIP2 war doch da auch noch.
Man könnte sich auch mal einen Namen überlegen, den man sich merken kann.
Die sind alle so basierend auf den gleichen Technologien. Deswegen muss da in letzter Zeit immer ein Z mit rein, weil das irgendwie Lempel-ZIF-Tralala ist und so. Deswegen kann man das nicht ohne Z machen. Und das andere ist dann immer der Huffman Lempel-ZIF. Hast du nicht gesehen? Also wenn man nach Tiefe einsteigt. Jedenfalls, er war nicht hinter der besten Kompressionsrate hinterher, sondern er wollte, deswegen auch der Name Z Standard, er wollte ein relativ durchschnittliches Komprimier-Ratio haben. Aber das halt in sehr, sehr, sehr schnell. Und ich bin der Meinung, er hat das gut geschafft. Und zwar ist sein Komprimierer besser vom Ratio her als Gezip, aber auch schneller. Und wenn das der Fall ist, wenn du sowohl besser als auch, also schneller bist und sowohl auch besser komprimieren kannst, dann ist der andere Komprimierer sozusagen komplett unnötig. Bei dem LZ4 war das so, das war ja so ein Kompromiss, den nimmst du, wenn du es schnell haben willst, wenn du es ein bisschen besser ratio haben willst, hast du halt Gezip oder einen anderen genommen. Oder wenn du halt sehr, sehr hoch komprimieren willst, nimmst du halt LZMA, dafür war der aber scheiße, scheiße, scheiße langsam. Und das lohnt sich nur, wenn du wirklich archivieren willst und wirklich nur einmal komprimierst, aber vielleicht ganz oft dekomprimierst oder halt für Backup oder so. Aber was ja jetzt heute so mehr die Anwendungsfälle sind, und zwar wenn du so eine gesamte Transport-Compression haben willst, das heißt du willst irgendwie was, ich will das von mir zu dir schicken und unsere Leitung ist halt relativ teuer oder schlecht oder langsam. Das heißt, ich will bei mir komprimieren, will das dann rüber schicken und du musst auch noch wieder dekomprimieren. Und da gibt es auch Benchmark, die das schon so messen. Und da wäre so ein LZ-AMA, der komprimiert zwar gut, aber bevor ich das komprimiert habe, in der Zeit hätte ich das auch mit der langsamen Leitung schon längst zu dir rüber geschickt. Deswegen bringt der da nicht so wirklich. Und der ganz schnelle LZ-4, der würde es zwar relativ schnell komprimieren, aber das Ergebnis wäre immer noch zu groß, was auf unserer langsamen Leitung auch wieder zu lange dauern würde. Und genau da kommt dieser Z-Standard irgendwie dazwischen, weil der ist halt relativ gut noch im Komprimieren und dabei auch noch ziemlich schnell. Und das ist meiner Meinung nach, um dann gleich danach zum nächsten Thema zu kommen, auf jeden Fall ein sehr, sehr heißer Kandidat für On-Disc-Compression, wenn man halt ZFS irgendwie seine Blöcke komprimiert. Da gibt es nämlich schon einen Gzip, habe ich auch mal ausprobiert, aber das ist so langsam, das kannst du einfach nicht benutzen, das macht alles so träge. Und dieser Z-Standard würde den einfach mal lock ersetzen. Jetzt hast du hier die schicke Grafik und dann kann man...
Warte mal, das Ding ist von Facebook?
Ja, der Typ ist irgendwie so Anfang des Jahres, hat ihn Facebook wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger eingekauft oder irgendwie so, da ist er zu Facebook gegangen. Also er hat ohne Facebook angefangen und ist dann zu Facebook gewechselt. Also der macht das jetzt mit deren Hilfe, könnte man sagen. Vielleicht brauchen die das auch irgendwie und dachten sich, wir fördern das mal. Das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, wie das geht. Das ist auf jeden Fall Open Source und ja... So und dieser Grafik hast du diese in... Die haben unsere Hörer ja später dann auch die Grafik richtig. Kann ich ja nur jetzt drüber erzählen.
Wenn man da drauf rumklickt, dann sieht man halt hier Compression Speed vs. Ratio, das ist hier auf dieser Homepage, also der GitHub Projekt Homepage drauf. Naja, sieht halt irgendwie schneller und bessere Kompression.
Genau, solange also der Punkt, der gesetzte von dem einen Kompremierer höher und weiter links ist als von dem anderen Kompremierer, bist du auf jeden Fall besser und der andere ist einfach komplett unnötig. Das heißt, mit dem Z-Standard, mit dem 1, 2, 3, 4, mit dem vierten Punkt von unten schon, bist du sowohl schneller und hast aber trotzdem auch schon eine höhere Kompressionsrate. Das heißt, der G-Zip ist einfach egal, in welchem Modus man ihn benutzt, ist nicht so gut wie Z-Standard in Modus 4 oder 5. Irgendwie so. Man kann das noch irgendwie ausreizen, indem man ihn noch schneller macht. Dann kann aber sein, dass der G-Zip besser sein könnte. Oder man macht ihn sehr, sehr, sehr schnell und dann ist man vielleicht nicht so gut wie G-Zip, aber reichlich schneller. Also ich finde, das ist mal was Neues. Das steht auch in dem Facebook, da haben wir einen relativ langen Artikel dazu, das ist jetzt nicht diese Seite, aber da gibt es auch, kann ich ja gleich mal raussuchen. Da erklären sie auch, dass G-Zip schon, es gibt es ja seit 20 Jahren und auch schon seit ewig gibt es natürlich welche, die besser komprimieren als G-Zip. Dann gibt es auch welche, die schneller sind, aber es gibt eigentlich fast keine so richtig oder sehr wenig, die sowohl schneller als auch besser sind und der hat das jetzt geschafft und auch nicht nur so ein bisschen, sondern auch gleich ganz ordentlich. Und die meinen auch, dieser Algorithmus ist erst am Anfang. Sie wollen da demnächst noch mehrere Optionen nachlegen und zwar, dass du ihn noch schneller einstellen kannst, bei weniger Ratio natürlich oder dass er noch besser komprimiert und dadurch auch noch ein bisschen langsam wird. Also, dass sie ihn noch dynamischer einsetzen kann, damit er möglichst breites Spektrum abfertigt. Das ist, könnte man sozusagen, das ist jetzt, ja nicht ganz, aber der Opus der Kompressionstechnologie, wie der Opus Codec, der deckt ja auch so diesen riesengroßen Bereich ab, von ganz kleiner Bitrate bis zu ganz hoher Bitrate ist er in allen Sachen eigentlich besser als die Konkurrenz und der schafft das hier noch nicht ganz, weil wie gesagt, die guten wie LZMA, die sind schon noch besser, aber halt scheiß langsam, aber der ist schon sehr, sehr gut. Also dieser Franzose, Jan Collette, der weiß schon, was er tut.
Ja, das wäre natürlich auch cool, wenn man das sozusagen in so ganz SCP und solchen Sachen irgendwie wenn die das ein bisschen automatisch mit drin hätten.
Ja, das müsste eigentlich gehen, weil das ist ja eigentlich so modulemäßig, die SSHs können das ja so aushandeln. Warum auch in SSH, ich weiß nicht seit wann sie Compression drin haben, eigentlich schon immer seit ich mich erinnern kann, warum sie das nicht auch mal gegen was schickeres irgendwie getauscht haben, ist mir nicht so ganz klar. Weil ich hab das, ist das erste was ich mache, wenn wenn ich hier so ein OS aufsetze, ist Compression on für SSH Connections. Weil dann will ich irgendwie meinen, wenn ich einen Top-Aufruf oder da die Logfiles lang scrollen lasse, dann muss das irgendwie flutschen. Und ja, da braucht man sowas. Also auch wirklich schnelles Leitung, das macht nochmal, wenn die CPUs schnell sind und gut komprimieren können, dann geht nochmal ein bisschen Latenz runter. Also ich finde das flutscht einfach besser, wenn ich da was mache.
Ich vergleiche das hier gerade mal. Also er macht Punkt ZST als Extension ran.
Genau.
Jetzt habe ich das gerade mal auf einem MB3 getestet, das war vielleicht ein bisschen unfair.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen, weil das sollte sich nicht komprimieren lassen.
Naja, so ein bisschen schon, und da ist tatsächlich GZ besser. Das könnte man dann mal nehmen, ein Disk Image oder sowas. Das müsste auch ganz gut gehen, oder?
Ja, aber ein Disk Image ist eventuell auch schon komprimiert.
Nimm einfach den Kernel, wenn du ihn noch findest.
Den Kernel? Ja, wo liegt denn der? Nicht mehr in rot, oder?
Den haben sie versteckt irgendwie. Ich hab ihn letztens auch gesucht. Ein bisschen peinlich. Der ist irgendwie nach Private gewandert oder so was. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau. Aber in Slash liegt er nicht mehr.
Die Sau. Einfach das Betriebssystem ohne Kernel ausgeliefert.
Nee, ist ein bisschen woanders hin gewandert.
Tja, was ist denn heute noch unkomprimiert?
Die Binary sind unkomprimiert.
Die Binary? Das ist ja mal ein großes Binary.
Wenn die mal noch unkomprimiert sind.
Du findest jetzt echt den Kernel, nicht? Der ist nicht in Private.
Vielleicht ist er da irgendwo. Ich dachte mir, ich guck mal lieber nach irgendeinem absurdgroßen Programm. Und das ist dann mal ein schönes Beispiel.
Wenn wir schon dabei sind, Apple hat auch irgendwas komisches gemacht, wenn man sich Beta-Versionen von Xcode runterlädt, sind die jetzt gepackt mit etwas, was Punkt Xzip heißt. X-I-P.
X-I-P. Die sind ja auch nicht klein, das sind ja immer noch 2-3 GB, die ich da runterlade, oder? Ja. Also das ist immer noch das komplette Xcode, was man da runterlädt, jedes Mal. Jedes Mal, wenn ich mein Xcode update, ist das so groß, als wenn ich mir sonst ein Serial installiert hätte.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das ist, wenn du den über den App-Store updatest. Es kann sein, dass er dann nur Teile davon update. Also du bist der Meinung, das wäre XZ oder irgendwie sowas?
Ja, das ist auch einer von diesen guten Kompromieren. Das ist ja mal so ein Unterschied zwischen dem Kompressionsalgorithmus, der Name hat und dann gibt es ja irgendwie noch wieder diese Tools, diesen Algorithmus benutzen und daraus so ein Archivformat haben, und das Archivformat hat ja auch nochmal wieder so ein Format. Das heißt zum Beispiel dieser L7 oder wie heißt der sonst?
Der L7-ZIP heißt der.
Genau, und LZMA und LZIP und so, das ist ja alles irgendwie ähnlich, aber die nutzen unterschiedliche Archivformate oder irgendwie so. Die hatten sich da mal nicht so richtig geeinigt, da hat es ein bisschen gedauert. Doch, jetzt geht's ja weiter. So ein ganz El Chippo-Kompression, der den immer schnell zusammengehackt hat. Den brauchen wir aber nicht mehr, weil LZ4 einfach mal 1000 Mal besser ist. So und das Gleiche kann man bei ZFS natürlich auch machen und hat jetzt einer gemacht. Und zwar hat jemand Native ZFS-Encryption eingebaut. Also jetzt, was ist heute Mittwoch? Also am Montag und gestern war die Open ZFS-Konferenz in San Francisco. Und da habe ich mir diesen einen Vortrag da mal angehört über Encryption. Da hat der Typ das mal vorgestellt. Also gab es als Stream und diesmal hat es auch einigermaßen funktioniert. Das war früher aber nicht so toll wie unsere Club-Streams. Da haben wir schon eine hohe Latte gelegt. Also das war jetzt so wie ein 50-Minuten-Vortrag. Kann man jetzt nicht alles wiederholen. Aber so grundsätzlich, der Code ist fertig. Also die Pull-Requests sind da. Das ist Native ZFS-Encryption. Heißt nicht, dass sozusagen die Files entcryptet werden, die du dahin speichern willst und ZFS darunter weiß nichts. Sondern das File ist entcryptet. Das ist nicht der Fall. Und das ist auch nicht der Fall, dass einfach die Blöcke, die ZFS nutzt, unten drunter verschlüsselt werden. So wie das Freebies D schon macht mit diesem Gehli. Du machst so einen Kryptocontainer und dann sagst du dem ZFS jetzt, hier, da drauf speicherst du dich. Also dass es das nicht mitkriegt. Sondern das Native heißt, dass das ZFS das komplett selbst macht. Das hat aber auch Nachteile und Vorteile. Also du kannst halt die Pool-Struktur noch sehen. Du kannst die Datasets noch sehen, also welche Filesystems da sind. Aber du kannst halt den Inhalt nicht mehr sehen. Das heißt, du könntest einen riesen Pool haben, der auch schon bootet, weil dein Boot-Filesystem ist halt nicht verschlüsselt, weil du willst ja davon booten. Und wenn es dann aber oben ist, loggst du dich ein, checkst alles klar, ist ja alles okay hier noch, hat keiner an meinen Daten rumgefuscht. Und dann mountest du halt den verschlüsselten Pool mit deinem Key und dann legt deine Kiste los. Das kann man dann alles machen. Und dadurch, dass das so native ist mit dem Encryption, gibt es da auch so Sachen, dass zum Beispiel Scrup, womit man sein ZFS checkt, das kann dann auch funktionieren, obwohl du das gar nicht entschlüsseln kannst. Sondern der kann die Daten ja so checken anhand der Checksum. Das muss er dir nicht entschlüsseln. Das heißt, er checkt das einfach so durch. Und bei dem Resilver wohl genauso. Also der kann dann merken, dass dieser eine Block kaputt ist, obwohl er verschlüsselt ist, holt sich dann von der zweiten Platte aus dem Mirror, holt sich den anderen verschlüsselten Block, und schiebt den da drüber und muss das nicht mal dekrypten dafür, sondern macht das einfach so. Und ja, ich finde das voll gut. Das ist, was die bei Oracle schon irgendwie ganz früh hatten. Aber dann haben sie ja kurz vorher irgendwie den Open Source-Stöpsel zugedrückt und dann konnte das nicht mehr mitgeforkt werden. Und das haben die jetzt sozusagen nachgereicht.
Hast du da einen Link für?
Da musst du mal auf die Open-ZFS-Seite gehen und da ist dann Werbung für diese Konferenz, die da gestern und vorgestern war. Und da wiederum ist der Talk. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Videos jetzt schon veröffentlicht sind. Ich habe das live geguckt und die sind halt eben nicht so schnell wie der Club mit Videos veröffentlicht und so. Es kann sein, dass das ein bisschen dauert. Aber der hat das alles sehr gut erklärt, wie sie das auch mit dem Key-Management machen und wie sie dafür sorgen, dass die Angriffe da nicht so richtig funktionieren, weil man ja, wenn man als Mensch so schwache Passwörter eingibt, dass es trotzdem auch mit Brute Force, du nicht einfach irgendwie diesen Key denn da durchrechnen kannst und so. Also ich hatte das Gefühl, der Typ hat wirklich Ahnung von was er da redet. Und das hat mir sehr, sehr, also es hat mich, also mich hat das voll überzeugt. Was ich ein bisschen schade finde, ist, dass das ist für Linux irgendwie gebaut. Das gibt's schon ein Pull-Request für, für OS X, OS X. Und der, ja Mac OS, schuldigung, genau, und dieser Jörg Lundmann oder weißt der auch diesen ZFS-Power für Mac OS macht, der hat auch da wohl viel mitgeholfen bei diesem Encryption. Deswegen kann man davon ausgehen, dass es demnächst gibt's dann ZFS auf dem Mac, dann mit Native Encryption. Und dann noch für dieses Illum OS gibt's das auch. Nur für Freebase, die halt irgendwie nicht, weil irgendwie habe ich da was gelesen von die bei Freebase, die haben ja ihr eigenes Krypto-Framework und überhaupt, und sie könnten das nicht integrieren oder wollen nicht oder irgendwie so ein Yada, Yada, Yada. Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen schade, weil genau da hätte ich es halt gerne gehabt. Aber vielleicht, nachdem der jetzt diesen Talk gegeben hat, vielleicht lassen sich ja die Freebase-Jungs auch überzeugen, dass der Typ da schon weiß, was er tut und dass das eine tolle Sache ist. Eine Sache, die noch auch sehr interessant war, da macht das ja der Arbeit bei so einer Firma, die das halt professionell brauchen, dieses Encryption-Feature. Und zwar wollen sie, dass ihre Kunden ZFS benutzen können und die Backups verschlüsselt zu denen in die Cloud schicken, aber halt verschlüsselt, er meint, damit sie eben nicht die Möglichkeit haben, das zu decrypten und auch nicht die Liability haben, das decrypten zu können, sondern dass nur der Kunde das kann. Also das heißt, du schickst dein verschlüsseltes Backup zu denen hin und holst es dir von da wieder, aber die Firma kann einfach genau nichts damit anfangen oder die, denen halt die Cloud da gehört, weil es alles einfach gekryptet ist und das hört sich auch sehr, sehr gut an.
Aber der Terrorismus, aber die Terroristen.
Ja, die können das dann halt auch nutzen, ne? Aber die Terroristen, die fahren auch Auto und so weiter. Telefonieren und nutzen Google. Ich glaub, die nutzen ganz schön viel Google, hab ich gehört.
Schlimm.
Sollte man verbieten. Sog dieses Internet, ist eigentlich nur voll von Kriminellen. Alles böse ZFS-Nutzer, Kryptomacher.
Also bei allen Talks steht unter Video und Slice noch TBA to be announced.
Dann kommt wahrscheinlich noch das nächste, was sie da hatten. Das interessiert mich auch. Hab ich aber dann natürlich saß an meinem Rechner, dachte alles klar, gleich kommt der Vortrag und dann klinke ich mich ein. Dann wurde ich natürlich wieder abgelenkt, wie das immer so ist. Dann hab ich ihn voll verpasst. Und zwar ist da ein Typ, der irgendwie das Scrubbing, wenn man sein ZFS mal durchchecken will, irgendwie optimiert hat. In einer sehr schlauen Art und Weise. Und das wollte ich mir eigentlich angucken, aber das habe ich verschnarcht.
Mach doch mal einen Link direkt auf diese Talks, die du jetzt erwähnt hast.
Ja, Open ZFS oder kann das nicht der Roddy machen? Du bist doch schon gerade auf der Seite, oder?
Ja, da war zum Summit da was, aber es war jetzt noch kein... Ich weiß nicht, ob die Talks einzeln verlinkt sind. Dann wäre das ja schon mal ganz hilfreich.
Also von dieser Seite aus sind die Talks einzeln verlinkt. Aber es sind auch nur ein Dutzend.
Ja, es ist ja nur eine ganz kleine Konferenz. Sie läuft über einen Tag und am zweiten Tag. Also gestern war es schon nur so Hackathon, wo die halt so ein bisschen da rumhacken.
Also es sind auch nur fünf Talks verlinkt. Und dazu steht dann immer nur so zwei Absätze lang was. Also solange jetzt keine Videos oder Slides kommen, ist das jetzt nur von begrenzter Interessanz.
Ja, ich würde ihnen einfach die Hauptseite für das Open ZFS geben und sonst nicht die Leute da durchklicken. Das macht ja mehr Sinn.
Ja, ich hab's auch gefunden.
Hackathon hätten sie ja gestern gleich mal diesen Z-Standard einbauen können. Das kann ja nicht so schwer sein, weil das Gezip ist ja schon da. Das heißt, du musst ja nur, jeder muss ja nur die, ja doch, das geht relativ einfach. Ich hab schon zweimal mit zwei Kumpels, jeweils zwei verschiedenen, hab ich einmal, was haben wir eingebaut? Snappy von Google hatten wir mal eingebaut als Komprimierer und ich glaub mit dem Erdgeist aus dem Club hab ich irgendwann mal, ich glaub LZO war's, haben wir eingebaut. Zusätzlich. Wurden ja aber beide nicht genommen, weil dann kam ja LZ4 und dann war das alles nicht mehr so top notch, was wir da benutzt hatten, aber so grundsätzlich geht das relativ easy. Also schreibst ja keinen neuen Code, du musst ja nur den, der für andere Komprimierer da ist, musst ja nur nehmen und auch so benutzen und dich einhängen in die Liste der Komprimierer. Also ist ja schon alles modular.
So wollen wir nochmal über Sierra reden.
Sierra Leone?
Wenn es da was zu sagen kippt, zu?
Das hat sich so wenig geändert von irgendwie sichtbaren Geschichten.
Das sind ja nicht die sichtbaren, sind die unsichtbaren.
Also Siri nutzt das, ich kann das nicht benutzen. Ich hab das zu Hause einmal probiert, weil ich hab außerdem draufgeklickt, dachte ich, okay, fragst mal nach der Uhrzeit oder irgendein Scheiß und das ging schon gleich so schief und dann hatte ich schon gleich wieder die Schnauze voll. Also nee, das geht gar nicht.
Aber das ist auch so neunmal klug irgendwie.
Ich benutze es immer nur auf der Apple TV und manchmal ist es wirklich zum Haare raufensitzen.
Ich hab Siri gefragt, was das Logo vom ersten FC Union Berlin ist. Und dann kam so ein ganz spitzes Bild. Na ja, sie hat das dahingeschrieben, das was ich gesagt habe, aber...
Okay, ist ja schonmal was.
Ja, gut, hat aber dann nicht viel geholfen und hat sie mir dann irgendwie die Liga der zweiten, also die aktuelle Tabelle der zweiten Bundesliga so gemacht.
Immerhin?
Hatt ich jetzt nicht nach gefragt, aber ist ja vielleicht mal, das war wahrscheinlich das einzige, was sie...
Sie hat Logo mit Liga verwechselt.
Das kann gut sein.
Hast du da genuschelt?
Aber was da ganz pfiffig war, war, ja, aber Union hätte ja die letzten vier Spiele gewonnen, sieht ja ganz gut aus. Das fand ich dann schon wieder ganz knuffig. Und stimmt auch.
Welcher Platz sind die jetzt?
Zweiter.
Ui, zweiter.
Da hat Pauli geputzt.
War letztes Spiel, ne?
War geil. Montag.
Wo war es dann?
Ja, war lecker.
Hier, oder?
Ja, alte Försterei.
Wie viel gewonnen?
2-0. Jetzt sind wir auch schon mit Fußball eingestiegen.
Ja, das ist, also, so eine Sache finde ich witzig so, wenn die versucht, so ein bisschen personal zu werden, weil du scheinst sie ja für FC Union zu interessieren, also beantwortet sie oder, ja, also sie hat ja Smalltalk gemacht. Sie hat dir ja was erzählt, was du nicht gefragt hast. Nein, das würde ich ja schon ein bisschen unter Smalltalk einbuchen.
Also diesen Bezug Liga-Logo habe ich jetzt tatsächlich so nicht gezogen, aber es hat schon auch Logo erkannt.
Also sobald es ja da stand.
Jaja, weil es ja da steht, so, ne. Von daher, sobald der Bundeslogo, keine Ahnung, was die von mir hält. Naja, trotzdem, wir haben ja über Sierra noch nicht geredet und es gibt ja schon noch so ein paar kleine Änderungen, ne.
Meine kleinste Lieblingsänderung. Und ich weiß nicht, ob wir das schon letztes Mal hatten.
Letztes Mal haben wir über Networking gesprochen, diese IPv6-Deschichte.
Ach so, ich mein was ganz anderes. Und zwar jetzt oben hier in den Menüs da, wie heißen die eigentlich, diese kleinen oben rechts? Jedenfalls, da gibt es doch den für diesen kleinen Lautsprecher, wo man früher nur die Lautstärke einrichten konnte, ne. Und der hat jetzt per Default, kann man jetzt auch das Output Device einstellen, was früher nur ging, wenn man die Alt-Taste gedrückt hat. Inzwischen muss man die Alt-Taste zwar noch drücken, wenn man auch das Input Device regeln will, oder einstellen will, aber inzwischen kann man jetzt mit einem ganz normalen Klick auswählen, über was man jetzt eigentlich irgendwie seinen Sound gerne hören würde. Und das finde ich schon, das ist seit Jahren fällig. Weil ich hab diesen Button fast nie für Lautstärke benutzt, aber immer mit Alt, um das Device auszuwählen.
Und der Regler ist jetzt horizontal und nicht mehr vertikal, das ich auch sehr schön fand.
Daran muss man sich glaube ich erstmal gewöhnen.
Nö, muss ich nicht.
Das haben sie schon nach 15 Jahren irgendwie begriffen, dass man vielleicht mal mehr als einen Lautsprecher an seinem Scheißsystem dran hat. Ja, jetzt wo sie selber Bluetooth-Kopfhörer machen, ist es auf einmal wichtig, schnell hin und her zu schalten. Soll ja ganz geil sein, ne? Diese komischen AirPods. Ob wir ehrlich gesagt nicht verstehen, wie man... Na okay, das ist jetzt nicht das Thema. Lass uns erstmal bei Sierra bleiben.
Was ich noch festgestellt habe, ist, weil ich bin ja so der Krypto-Fan, dass auf dem iPhone mache ich das ja schon eine Weile, aber auf dem Mac OS, danke, gegen das immer irgendwie nicht so richtig. Und das tut jetzt auch einfach irgendwie hier... Gebt da einfach meine Gegenstelle ein, sag irgendwie, was hier die ID von mir ist und die ID von der Gegenstelle ist, dann fragt er mich noch nach dem ShareSecret, weil ich mach das gerade noch mit ShareSecret.
Warte mal, du redest jetzt von VPNs.
VPNs, so nennt man die heutzutage.
Wie nannte man sie denn früher?
Gar nicht.
Ist IPsec denn immer VPN? IPsec ist doch nur ein Betriebsmodus.
VPN ist für mich so ein Wort wie Firewall, das kann man so und so lösen, ich weiß nicht genau. Also ich...
Passt auf, sonst muss Clemens wieder Tischkanten kaputt machen.
Das wird er jetzt wahrscheinlich eh schon, der nagt hier.
Jedenfalls tut das jetzt sehr gut. Ich kann hier klicken und sofort ist das oben und eine IPv6-Adresse kommt dann auch, falls du jetzt keine hättest, hätte ich dann eine IPv6... Nee, aber durch meinen VPN kommt dann eine IPv6 zu mir auch. Und im Café sitzt du nur mit IPv4 und ich denke, IPv6 ist eigentlich viel cooler, zack, VPN angemacht. Und dann habe ich eine VPN mit IPv4 und IPv6-Adresse. Genau.
Wohin dann?
Zu meinem Endpunkt.
Ja, aber was?
Strongsworn. Da hat mich letztens einer angetwittert, er hätte das nicht hinbekommen, mit FreeBSD und Strongsworn. Bei mir tut das. Er muss nochmal Doku lesen. Ich weiß, dass alle von mir wollen, dass ich das noch mal veröffentliche, aber ich habe ja keinen Blog überhaupt. Ich mach das demnächst nochmal mit einem Kumpel aus dem Klub fertig, dass es auch schick Zerts benutzt und keine Scherz-Secrets. Dass es jetzt alles auch noch top und schmuck aussieht, weil es jetzt nur noch so geht, aber es ist alles noch nicht so schick.
Wenn du so wollen, sind Slack einfach Support machen. Wie beständig er hier an seinem Podcast kaputt gedreht ist.
Ja, aber irgendwie tun die gerade nicht mehr. Ich glaube, ich habe die Pokestops kaputt gedreht. Diese App, das geht auch gar nicht. So ein Neustart, das ist schon unglaublich.
Wenn er nicht mehr will, dann musst du ihn einfach killen.
Was hast du hier noch aufgeschrieben? Hat sich jetzt noch was mit SSH geändert?
Ja, und zwar muss man das kurz mal erklären, was das ist. Also man kann ja mit SSH auf einen anderen Rechner springen, um sich da schnellmäßig irgendwie auszutoben. Aber wenn man ja ein bisschen Profi ist, und ich hoffe, das sind wir alle, dann macht man das natürlich nicht per Passwort, sondern man hinterlegt auf dem anderen Rechner den lokalen Key, den man sich erzeugt hat. Also den Public Key? Den Public Teil davon, genau, den privaten, hält man. Und dann lockt man sich ein. Das heißt, keiner kann irgendwie das Passwort von der Tastatur ablesen, wenn man sich woanders einlockt. Und man kann sogar dieses Key-File auch ohne Passwort machen. Das heißt, du lockst dich einfach ein, du musst gar kein Passwort eingeben, oder du kannst da ein Passwort drauflegen, aber das ist halt für den Key. Und der, der dein Passwort sieht, was du da tippst, der hat halt den Key nicht, kann sich auf der anderen Seite also immer noch nicht einloggen. Und jeder, der Brute Force auf dein Rechner macht und versucht, sich einzuloggen, hat keine Chance, weil Key Only, das geht einfach nicht. Deswegen will man eigentlich immer mit Keys arbeiten. So, jetzt gibt es aber noch den Fall, dass man auf Rechner, also der eigene Rechner ist jetzt mal A, man hüpft auf Rechner B, man will aber eigentlich auf einen Rechner C drauf, der nur von Rechner B erreichbar ist. Wenn nicht, müsst ihr zurückspielen, euch das nochmal anhören. So, wenn...
Ja, so ein Middleman, der halt nur einen Zugang hat.
Genau, so ein Jump-Horse, wie auch immer man das nennt. Und wenn aber Rechner C auch nur mit Key ist, dann will man eventuell sein Key ja nicht auf Rechner B hinterlegen. Deswegen gibt es sowas wie Agent Forwarding. Das heißt, du sagst bei SSH minus Groß A, das heißt, der eigene Key wird zunächst mitübertragen in diesen Agent und wenn du von Rechner B dann auf Rechner C springst, dann wird der Key aus dem Agent geholt. Das ist jetzt mal so grob umschrieben. Ihr könnt jetzt gerne Tischkanten beißen, ist mir egal. Aber so geht das. Aber seit Sierra geht das nicht mehr, weil die Keys, die man hat, nicht mehr default irgendwie in diesem Agent drin sind. Und deswegen muss man die jetzt immer von Hand reinmachen. Und dann hab ich mal eine Weile gegoogelt, ob das ein Sierra-Problem ist oder was da irgendwie los ist. Und dann hat einer ganz schlau geschrieben, naja, die bei Sierra, die haben halt von Open SSH 6 auf Open SSH 7 gewechselt. Und dort gibt's jetzt eine neue Option, die heißt Add Keys to Agent. Und die ist anscheinend per Default auf No oder irgendwie so. Und deswegen sind die Keys nicht mehr drin, werden nicht mit übertragen und deswegen kannst du das mit dem Jumping irgendwie nicht so gut machen. Du müsstest vorher immer manuell SSH minus Add, glaube ich, machen und dein Key irgendwie zu dem Agent dazu addieren. Ist das nicht SSH Add? Doch, SSH Add, genau. Aber eigentlich muss man nur diese Option auf Yes setzen und dann hat sich das Problem erledigt und dann ist gut.
Aber ich hab doch da schon, also ich habe in meinen SSH-Config immer das Setting Forward, Agent, Yes. Das reicht jetzt nicht mehr?
Na, dann mach das doch mal mit dem Jumping, ob das immer noch so funktioniert. Bei mir tat das nicht mehr. Ja, außer du addierst vorher dein Key zu dem Agent.
Ja, ich dachte die Option reicht da vollkommen aus.
Na, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da überhaupt irgendwelche speziellen Optionen hatte für, bin mir nicht so sicher. Ich muss mir das demnächst halt sowieso dann alles nochmal neu angucken, weil ich glaube, man kann auch sein Key verschlüsseln und den aber dann auch in der Keychain ablegen, das geht nämlich, weil das ist irgendwie kombiniert hier irgendwie.
Nee, du kannst das, du kannst die Passphrase von dem Key kannst du in der Keychain ablegen.
Ja genau, das meine ich. Also ja, nicht den Key selbst, sondern die Passphrase.
Das geht aber schon ewig.
Ja, das muss ich mir halt nochmal genau angucken, dass das auch alles wieder genau so ist, weil ich glaube, ich hab mir diesmal ein Key erstellt, weil ich hab letztens mal erneuert, weil man soll jetzt auf RSA umstellen oder eigentlich diese Elliptic Curve und so.
Guck dir die GitHub-Anleitung an, da steht als letzter Punkt, wie man das macht, mit dem SSH Agent irgendwie auch.
Welches GitHub? Ach so, das, dass man da...
Du kannst ja bei GitHub selber auch einen Key hinterlegen und da gibt es eine Anleitung, wie du das machst. Und der letzte Schritt von dieser Anleitung, der erklärt quasi, wie du den Key...
Ja, das sollte man tun, dass der da nicht so einfach...
Beziehungsweise du gibst eigentlich nur dem Agent bekannt, dass es jetzt diesen neuen Key gibt und dann fragt er das nächste Mal nach dem Passwort und ob er in den Keychain ablegen soll oder nicht.
Ja, das heißt, dass Apple dann auch dieses SSH-Ad oder den Agent Keychain kompatibel gemacht hat.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, schon seit Ewigkeiten.
Naja, weil die benutzen das ja auch dann, ne? Ja, ich hab das auch noch nicht probiert. Wie gesagt, wenn man den Key zu dem Agent addiert mit diesem SSH-Ad, das hält ja auch so lange, bis man halt den nächsten Reboot von seinem Rechner macht. Das ist mir natürlich dann besonders häufig aufgefallen, als jetzt im Sommer irgendwie jede Woche ich einmal für das neue Beta-Sierra irgendwie booten musste. Das heißt, ich musste jede Woche immer wieder feststellen, das ist scheiße, ich muss ja diese Keys addieren. Und irgendwann geht es einem ja dann doch auf den Sack und dann googelt halt manchmal, was das Problem ist.
Und sie haben, glaube ich, die DSR-Keys jetzt deprecated, ne? Die funktionieren nicht mehr so richtig.
Das kann sein, da war irgendwas. Deswegen hab ich mir auch im Sommer schon irgendwann im Mai oder so halt RSA-Key erzeugt. Aber eigentlich, glaube ich, soll man Elliptic Curve machen. Was mich ja wundert ist, oder was ich mich frage ist, weil man ja nie genau weiß ist, RSA jetzt gerade hat das einer kaputt gemacht oder hat das Elliptic Curve einer kaputt gemacht oder hat das DSR einer kaputt gemacht oder das soll ja jetzt angeblich kaputt sein. Warum man die alle nicht in Kombination benutzt und nicht nur einen davon, sondern so ein Key, der aus allen dreien irgendwie besteht, weil dann müssen sie halt alles drei kaputt machen. Weil wenn mir einer sagt, ja, hier benutzt man Elliptic Curve, dann weiß ich ja nicht, wer so dahinter steckt. Vielleicht sagt das ja der, der weiß, dass das auch schon gehackt ist oder dass sie wissen, wie man es umgehen kann und will mich halt dann genau da in diese Richtung schieben. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen Verschwörungstheoriemäthig, aber ich meine, wenn man einfach drei Key-Verfahren kombinieren würde, dann hätte der Attacker schon seine Schwierigkeiten, weil man müsste alle drei kaputt machen.
Also soweit ich weiß, gibt es ja auch irgendwie 1001 Elliptic-Curves, die man verwenden kann, die alle unterschiedlich gut sind.
Aber wenn das Konzept komplett kaputt ist, weiß ich halt eben nicht. Versteht ja auch so eine Mathematiker, versteht das ja keiner.
Elliptic-Curve ist ja im Prinzip Diffie-Hellman, nur dass du irgendwie anders wegmachst.
Im Prinzip verstanden hast du das aber auch nicht.
Es gab irgendwo mal einen Talk, wo ich immerhin in die Nähe gekommen bin, zu verstehen, worum es gehen könnte.
Ich habe hier irgendwo noch, glaube ich, einen Artikel, den ich mal gelesen habe dazu.
Zumindest habe ich verstanden, worum es Elliptic-Curve heißt, was ja schon mal was ist.
Und Timmy, bist du immer noch am rumjumpen mit SSH?
Ja, ich muss hier gerade noch mal irgendwie meine Fritzbox neu starten. Meine Fritzbox nochmal hier. Weil ich habe gerade zu wenig Hosen draus, mit denen ich das rumtesten kann.
Ich kann ja mal was in eigener Sache sagen. Und zwar wollte ich das eigentlich schon zum letzten Mal, aber da bin ich ja dann ausgefallen.
Du bist Star-Podcaster.
Nee, das nicht. Also das auch. Aber darüber wollte ich jetzt nicht reden. Ich habe doch da so eine Mac-App im Mac-App-Store seit Unzeiten, also sprich, seit er eröffnet wurde. Und die App ist auch noch älter. Und da habe ich jetzt den Stöpsel gezogen und die auf Free gesetzt, weil ich da jetzt keine Lust mehr zu habe, die weiter zu maintainen.
Die schmeißen den auch demnächst eher raus, wenn du dich nicht kümmerst, oder?
Das Problem ist, dass ich die irgendwann mal auf Garbage Collection umgestellt habe. Und das Sierra funktioniert Garbage Collection nicht mehr. Das haben sie irgendwie zu... Was war das davor? Diese Berge nicht merken. El Capitan. Zu El Capitan hatten sie schon angekündigt, okay, das ist jetzt das letzte Release, was noch Garbage Collection schon haben wird. Und das Release danach dann nicht mehr. Das stand in den Beta-Release-Notes von Capitan schon drin. Und da dachte ich mir, jetzt müsstest du eigentlich mal, müsstest du, habe ich aber nie gemacht. Und jetzt habe ich einfach gesagt, ja, okay. Läuft halt jetzt nicht mehr und das Sierra ist gut.
Da hat es sich wieder voll gelohnt, dass ich diese neuen Sachen immer aussitze. Weil dieses Garbage Collection hat mir irgendwie nie gefallen. Ich dachte, ich setze das aus und es hat tatsächlich funktioniert. Ich bin gleich zu arg rüber gesprungen und es hat damit mit diesem Scheiß nichts zu tun.
Ich glaube, als ich Garbage Collection angefangen hatte, gab es arg noch nicht.
Ja, aber da gab es ja noch, dass man es halt manuell macht.
Ja, genau. Aber das war halt auch ein Pain.
Ja, aber ich habe das seit 2002 manuell gemacht. Das hatte ich schon einigermaßen im Griff, würde ich mal behaupten.
Naja, es hatte sich für diese App halt auch so ein Perfect Storm zusammen entwickelt. Das Erste ist, dass ich die App hatte, die ich im App Store hatte, als er aufgemacht wurde, und dann gab es im App Store noch kein Sandboxing. Und dann hätte ich die App auf Sandboxing umbauen müssen, was relativ schwierig ist, wenn man eine App schreibt, die eigentlich auf die ganze Festplatte zugreifen möchte. Und dann, naja, das hatte ich schon so halbwegs hingekriegt, und dann kam halt OpenSSL.
Was ist denn deine App überhaupt?
Die vierte, doppelte, duplizierte Dateien.
Duplicate Finder. Du brauchst dafür OpenSSL?
Ja, für die nicht App Store Version, bzw. auch für die App Store Version, für die Lizenz-Krypto. Genau, weil die sollte man ja mal Geld bezahlen. Haben ja auch ein paar Leute gemacht. Und es ist mir bis heute nicht gelungen, das irgendwie anders zu machen als mit OpenSSL. Ich hab dann noch versucht, irgendwie LibreSSL zu kompilieren und zu verwenden, aber das ist mir irgendwie auch nicht geglückt. Du bist doch jetzt dabei, oder?
Er benutzt das doch, wenn du guckst, dass der OpenSSL steht da, gebaut ist mit LibreSSL.
Das mag sein, aber du kriegst keine Hedder-Files dafür. Also das wird einfach nicht unterstützt. Du kannst das nicht mehr als... Vorher war das halt einfach, du hast halt gesagt, hier, include das und dann hattest du den Kram und musstest sonst nichts machen irgendwie. Also vielleicht noch irgendwie die richtige Library linken. Und naja, dann hab ich irgendwann gesagt, jetzt schmeiß den Scheiß hin und gut ist. Jetzt will ich irgendwann noch zumindest diesen ganzen Krypto-Krempel ausbauen und noch ein paar andere Sachen irgendwie feilen und dann kommt's auf GitHub und alles gut. So bis Ende des Jahres hab ich mir vorgenommen, mal sehen, ob das klappt. Ja, da geht's dahin. Eine App, die Prä-App Store ist. Ja, auf der Download-Seite steht noch. Ja, und die und die Version läuft noch unter 10.2 und die und die Version läuft noch unter 10.3 und die und die Version läuft noch unter 10.4. Hat aber kein 32-Bit mehr, weißt du so. Ja, du kannst sogar noch eine Power-PC-kompatible Version runterladen. Das ist ja. Aber jetzt halt nicht mehr. Nee, naja, gut, sagen wir mal so. Auf ARK hatte ich sie schon umgestellt. Na ja, ich versuchte irgendwie mit Common-Kropter zu machen, aber das hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Und ach, das ist alles ein... Weil er nicht schnell genug hinterher ist, dann hängt ein Apple gnadenlos ab.
Was ja jetzt auch noch so eine Neuigkeit ist, das bezieht sich aber jetzt auf iOS 10. Bezieht sich ja auf iOS 10. Da gibt es ja jetzt dieses neue Call-Kit bei iOS 10. Also, dass Apps sich quasi in das System so einklinken können, als wären sie eine Telefon-App sozusagen.
Na ja gut, da haben wir ja drüber geredet, dass es kommen soll, aber jetzt sind halt auch die Apps draußen.
Jetzt haben sie es tatsächlich ernst gemacht.
Ja, Skype kam gerade erst ein Update durch, heute oder so. Die machen das jetzt auch.
Skype macht es jetzt auch? Ah, okay, die haben noch gefehlt. Für mich natürlich sehr schön, dass es das jetzt auch mit GroundWire gibt, was so ein ganz korrekter SIP-Kline des St. Clemens hier mal aufgebracht hat, der hervorragend auch so als Studio-Link-Endpoint funktioniert. Einziges Problem ist, dieses Call-Kit, also ich meine, jetzt klingelt zwar das Telefon und man kriegt jetzt sozusagen die Aufmerksamkeit am Telefon. So weit, so gut, nur bin ich ja jetzt auch schon wieder ein paar Jahre weiter und benutze ja mein Telefon immer silent. Das heißt, ich kriege das jetzt trotzdem nicht mit, weil meine Erwartungshaltung war ja, dass wenn jetzt mein Telefon klingelt, dass auch noch meine Uhr klingelt. Aber das tun sie natürlich nicht. Das heißt, die Uhr klingelt nur, wenn du einen normalen Telefonanruf kriegst und wenn du jetzt halt irgendwie so einen Internetanruf kriegst, der jetzt eigentlich so ein bisschen als wichtiger einsortiert werden sollte, dann stehst du halt immer noch blöd da. Also ich mein, schon besser als vorher, aber das fand ich dann doch ein bisschen enttäuschend.
Aber das hatst du in der letzten Sendung schon rumgeheult, oder?
Aber nicht mit der Apple Watch. Nee, da hab ich ja jetzt erst rausgefunden.
Aber da hast du schon gehört.
Gerade erst gehört.
Nicht dein Ernst. Okay, dann nehm ich das jetzt zurück, wir nehmen das raus.
Wir schneiden das weg.
Du solltest selber mal meine Sendung hören.
Ich hab im Slack mal so ein schönes Bild zum Thema Samsung und abbrennende Telefone gepostet. Ja, relativ alt, aber ich fand's trotzdem sehr nett.
Ja, alt.
Sind die alle Themen schon abgearbeitet, oder wie?
Ja, heut war ja nix, hab ich ja gesagt. Heute hatten wir auch keine Kraft, neue Themen zu schaffen. Wir können uns natürlich noch über die Berliner Wahl unterhalten.
Und was genau willst du da sagen? Dass die Piraten es gerade mal so vor die Tierschutzpartei geschafft haben in Prozenten?
Nein, dass in Friedrichshain die Partei irgendwie in einem BVV mit eingezogen ist.
Nein, ich will nicht wirklich über die Wahl reden, weil ich finde, da gibt's nicht sehr viel zu sagen.
Ich fand die auch nicht überraschend.
Nee, ich fand die auch nicht überraschend. Überraschend fand ich nur so die finale Inszenierung des Piratenabgangs, das war dann doch ein bisschen over the top.
Der Killer-Pirat? Oder wie war die Tat, die Schlagzeile?
Nee, doch, das war ganz schön schlecht.
Das war richtig schlecht, ja.
Ja, damit ist das Ding jetzt auch wirklich durch. Du bist jetzt irgendwie Podcaster geworden, habe ich gehört, habe ich gelesen im Internet.
Ja, so ein Werbe-Posting für die Firma. Ich dachte, naja, dann erzählst du mal was. Ja, im Prinzip ist es so, dass es da, naja, wie jede größere Firma, gibt es da eine Marketing-Abteilung und die wollen irgendwelche News haben auf ihrem Blog und haben halt gefragt, wer könnte denn mal was zu seinem Hobby erzählen? Und ein Kollege hat was zur Fitness erzählt und einer hat was zum Hobbyschreinern erzählt und ich hab halt was zum Podcasting erzählt und hab mir dazu das Equipment von dem Herrn Prittlauf ausgeliehen und das in die Kamera gehalten. Und das wurde auch sehr schön abgelichtet, muss ich sagen. Das stimmt. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Geld die Fotografin gekriegt hat, aber sie hat ihren Job auf jeden Fall gut gemacht.
Ja genau, das ist nämlich mein Mobil-Set. So schön hab ich das selber noch nicht dokumentiert bekommen.
Bitte, also von mir aus kannst du die Fotos verwenden. Ich weiß allerdings nicht, ob da...
Die Fotos? Na ja, Fotos kann ich auch noch selber machen, aber ich glaube, ich habe das jetzt noch nicht so sehr gepostet. Das war halt irgendwie...
Also ich habe versucht, möglichst viele sinnvolle Links unterzubringen zu auch anderen interessanten Podcasting-Projekten. Ja, sehr gelungen. Dachte ich mir, wenn schon Werbung, dann bitte auch in die andere Richtung.
Ich frage mich immer nur, wer liest das?
Das weiß ich nicht, aber mich haben ein halbes Dutzend Kollegen darauf angesprochen, fanden das interessant.
Die Frage ist, ob du das außerhalb von Ebay irgendjemand liest.
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Das wäre doch eigentlich auch mal ganz cool.
Jetzt, wo wir Werbung für die Werbung gemacht haben, liest sie vielleicht jemand.
Ein unglaublicher Spike in unserem Kleinanzeigen-Blog. Der Roddy, der muss ja wirklich...
Wir sollten öfter über Roddy sprechen, wenn die sich jetzt denken.
Genau, zentral für die Zukunftsperspektiven von Ebay machen bringen. Ohne Roddy läuft da nichts. So Leute.
Da hab ich ja hier über diesen Stimmgewaltchor berichtet, über den ich, indem ich da mal eine Weile lang mitgesungen hab. Und da meinte der eine so, oha, das haben wir direkt als Spike gemerkt. Also das war nicht zu übersehen. Haben doch relativ viele Leute dann geklickt.
So, hat noch jemand ein Thema? Oder wollen wir heute mal früh Schluss machen? Wir sind irgendwie themlos. Na, wenn uns nichts einfällt, fällt uns nichts ein.
Halb elf ist schon fast so ein bisschen deprimierend.
So ein Chat wurde schon der Finger in die Wunde gelegt.
Welche denn?
Reicht nicht, ne?
Ich mein, das ist doch wirklich ein Laden, der...
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, sie haben die Hardware-Sparte eingespart. Ich meine, Hardware war ja immer das größte Argument, diese Tastatur, die Blackberry hatte. War eigentlich, naja gut, und ihre E-Mail-Anbindung über... Jaja, ihre Mailserver. Mailserver und die Hardware-Tastatur.
Die Hardware-Tastatur hatten alle.
Haben sie noch Mailserver?
Hat anscheinend keiner gekauft, war wohl doof.
Nein, die Hardware-Tastatur war nie ein Argument. Weil es gab ja nichts anderes.
Ich sehe auf einen Blick alle meine eingehenden Nachrichten, Telefone und so weiter. Auf dem Telefon. Als Software-Bestandteil.
Man sieht seine Mails.
Du hast nicht wie bei Apple, mit dieser Mitteilungszentrale, wo alles drin ist, was gerade passiert ist, was du rauslöschen kannst, sondern eher so, all deine E-Mail-Konten sind da drin, SMS sind da drin, Apps, die direkt in den HAP hineinschreiben können, Twitter als Beispiel wäre dann auch da drin. Das fand ich sehr schön. Ja, deswegen ist mein iPhone ja auch nur ein Telefon zum Pokemon Go spielen und Kamera. Und das Kamera.
Blackberry ist doch so eine stinklangweilige Schlips-Company, ohne Vision.
Dieses Telefon ist... Vielleicht sollte ich mir einen Schlips kaufen.
Ab heute nur noch in Schlips, Lety.
Ab heute nur noch in Schlips. Ich brauch noch so einen Bassbird-Bingo-Katalog, damit ich so ein bisschen damit auch noch auftrumpfen kann.
Ja, kein Problem.
Aber du wolltest doch über iOS abbrennen. Ich würde dir ja gerne mithelfen.
Ja, das ist mir aufgefallen, jetzt eben so im Zuge des Wechsels. Was ist mit dieser verdammten Musik-App passiert, dass man...
Also du vergleichst jetzt aber nicht mit iOS 9, sondern so grundsätzlich.
Grundsätzlich.
Bei iOS 9 aber noch, da sah die Musik-App eigentlich ganz okay aus, die Farben ein bisschen an die Alben. Ich weiß, ich hatte mir das in der Sendung schon. Aber das muss man einfach noch mal sagen. Sie sieht einfach scheiße aus.
Ja, nicht nur, dass sie scheiße aussieht. Ich möchte bitte nicht, dass meine Alben, wenn sie durchgehört sind, aufhören. Und ich möchte standardmäßig diesen Scheiß-Repeat-All-Button sehen. Aber den gibt's schon, ne?
Ich hatte ja immer genervt, weil ich komm da ab und zu drauf. Und dann weiß ich nicht, und man konnte ja mit diesem Shuffle noch nie erkennen, ist es nun an oder aus.
Das hat mir auch jemand berichtet. Das ist mir an mir halt vorbeigegangen. Die neuner Version hab ich ja nie gesehen. Und ich weiß nur, ich glaube vorher war das auch relativ nah beieinander, dass du nicht aus Versehen drauf kommen konntest, sondern eher bei der Musikauswahl hattest, dass du den Shuffle drücken konntest und gleichzeitig aber auswählen konntest. Es soll alles immer wiederholen. Ich hab's irgendwie gegoogelt.
Aber wenn der jetzt weg ist, finde ich das gut. Ich weiß auch, wie die das bei Apple machen. Und zwar, die sammeln ja die Daten hier. Und von jeder Aktion sammeln die ja auch die Daten. Die wissen genau, wie du auf den Hauptbutton drückst. Und die wissen auch genau, wie oft irgendwie Repeat oder Shuffle gedrückt wird. Und wahrscheinlich haben sie festgestellt, das nutzt kein Schwein. Und haben es mal in die hintere Ecke geschoben.
Witzig, ich nutze ständig den Shuffle. Ich bin einfach komisch.
Und die Apple, die schwimmen halt mit der Welle. Oder wollen, dass alle mit ihrer Welle schwimmen, wie auch immer man das dreht. Nee, aber die iOS 9, da sah das mit der Musik irgendwie, wenn die Band ein blaues Album hatte, dann war die Seite, wo dieses Album und die Songs waren, die war dann halt auch so blau angehaucht. Das war alles so ein bisschen, dass jedes Album auch so ein bisschen individuell und gut aussah. Weil es farblich immer gepasst hat vom Font, dass sie dann eigentlich schon...
Nee, es hat nicht immer, nicht immer gut gepasst.
Ja, aber das hätten sie noch irgendwie fixen können. Ich fand das war schon ziemlich gut. Und vor allem hoher Wiedererkennungswert. Du konntest an der Farbe schon gleich auf Kilometer Entfernung sehen, alles klar, das ist jetzt das Album. Das war einfach schick. Was ist, jetzt haben sie es rausgemacht. Das ist einfach weg. Jetzt ist hier alles so stinkend weiß. Und komisch. Und auf der anderen Seite, also wie soll man sagen, die Musik war eigentlich immer relativ dunkel gestaltet in iOS 9. Jetzt ist es irgendwie wieder weiß und hell. Und auf der anderen Seite haben sie aber jetzt die Uhr. Also hier, wie heißt das, Clock oder was? Ja genau, die Clock. Da haben sie alles von weiß nach schwarz gewechselt.
Ja, das finde ich auch komisch.
Wollen sie alles weiß machen oder wollen sie alles schwarz machen? Das eine wechseln sie in die eine Richtung, das andere wieder in die andere Richtung. Das passt vom Stil irgendwie überhaupt gar nicht zusammen.
Also was ich bei dir, was ich zum Thema Musik, ich weiß nicht, habt ihr letztes Mal über den Musik-Act am Ende von dieser Keynote gesprochen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir darüber gesprochen haben, ich glaube nicht.
Weil irgendwie, ihr kanntet die auch alle nicht, ne? Ich hab mir ja dann mal den Spaß gemacht und hab dann mal in der Musik-App einfach mal so die aktuellen Charts gehört. Da ist ja dieses Lied, was die am Anfang gemacht hat, auch drin. Und wenn du das dann mal im Vergleich hörst, ist das gar nicht schlecht zu der ganzen Scheiße, die da sonst so drin ist. Also macht dir mal den Spaß und hör dir mal in der Musik-App die aktuellen Charts an.
Ich hör mir nie Charts an.
Das ist unglaublich.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir sind einfach zu alt für sowas. Das ist alles.
Na ja gut, ich mein, Sport ist ja nun sehr relativ. Was der eine mag? Was, so Modern Talking oder was?
Nee, Modern Talking war eine andere Art von Scheiße. Also, ja, nee, so viel so, halt so dicke Hose-Rapper und dann so...
Also wie immer.
Passt doch total zu Apple mit ihren Beats-Kopfhörern.
Und dann so ein bisschen Schmachzeug und dann halt so total tot produzierter Pop. Also, wo du dann halt irgendwie eine Hookline hast und die spielen sie drei Minuten lang. Und Text kommt irgendwie auch nicht dazwischen und lautet so ein Zeug. Also es ist irgendwie ganz, ganz merkwürdig. Also nicht, dass jetzt das, was diese Sia da macht, so besonders spannend wäre. Also gerade der eine Song, den sie am Anfang, der klingt so, als hätten sie irgendwie von drei Liedern irgendwie den Refrain zusammen gebastelt und dann noch ein bisschen AOAO dazwischen gemacht. Also es ist irgendwie...
Vielleicht gibt es auch sowas wie den Paper-Generator für wissenschaftliche Paper auch für Musik, also für schlechte Popmusik.
Ja, es hat ja schon KLF schön demonstriert, wie man irgendwie erfolgreiche Popmusik so aus der Retorte durchstarten kann. Da haben sie extra ein Buch drüber geschrieben. Das war doch mit Ankündigungen seiner Zeit, was wir so angekündigt haben, wir machen jetzt hier mal einen Top One-Hit und dann haben sie es gemacht und dann fand es auch statt.
Ja, und dann haben sie irgendwie eine Mille verbrannt.
Dann haben sie die Kohle dann verbrannt, genau.
Verbrannt so richtig, im Sinne von ins Feuer geworfen. Eine Mille Pfund in Papier einfach mal verhalten.
The Copyright Liberation Front. Das sind richtige Discordia im Sinne von richtige, echte Discordia. Also das volle Programm. Nicht Leute, die irgendwie so ein bisschen so discordisch sind, sondern wenn du halt mal so in die Texte reinhörst, dann ist sozusagen alles voll mit Illuminaten-Anspielungen und The Full Monty.
Und die leben jetzt von ihrer Million, die sie nicht verbrannt haben schön irgendwo.
The Ancients of Momo und so weiter. Also es ist sozusagen alles komplett drin verwurstelt in ihrem Programm. Ja, KLF ist grandios.
Also es gab da irgendwann mal eine großartige Doku zu, wo sie halt dieses mit dem Verbrennen von dem Geld... Irgendwie so. Und ich fand das so geil, wie sie am nächsten Morgen, die dann auch gefilmt haben und so eine komplette Carter-Stimmung herrschte, wo ihnen dann so aufgegangen ist, Scheiße, wir haben jetzt wirklich eine Mille Pfund einfach verbrannt und die sind jetzt weg. Das war so, fand ich irgendwie lustig.
Nee, sie sind wirklich total krass. Ich meine, das sind halt richtige, richtige, aufrichtige Künstler. Das geht kaum noch, kaum noch konsequenter. Und das muss man sich echt mal, sollte man sich wirklich mal anschauen, wenn man das irgendwie noch nicht gesehen hat. Und KLF ist einfach grandios. Es war ja auch grandioser Pop, den sie gemacht haben. Aber halt auch wirklich so mit Ansagen. Wie hieß dieses Buch, was sie irgendwie gemacht haben? Da macht er extra so ein Buch rausgebracht, wie man so ein Number One-Hit macht. Da krieg ich da jetzt was durcheinander. Ja, genau. The Manual. How to have a Number One the easy way. Genau. Dann haben sie einfach beschrieben, wie man mit einer Handvoll Samples einen Number One-Hit konstruiert. Damit haben sie sozusagen das ganze System quasi gezeigt. Ja, ist fantastisch. Super geile Discord, Top Notch, Number One.
Gerne wieder.
Also krasse Typen.
So, war das schon alles so eine iOS-Beschwerde? Nee, ich hab ja Lotti gar nicht ausreden lassen.
Ich auch, Dennis.
Das wär anders.
Nee, das ist mir in der Tat aufgefallen, aber irgendwas war noch an der UI, dass ich mir so langsam gedacht hab, wieso müsst ihr immer alles versuchen, jetzt noch anders zu machen.
Du hattest letztes Mal behauptet, dass sie den Systemfond geändert haben.
Bisschen dicker.
Da bin ich irgendwie...
Nein, die haben nicht den Fond geändert, sie haben das Gewicht des Fonds etwas dicker.
Naja, das ist ja geändert, aber...
Na, das wär spellbar. Doch, die Uhrzeit, doch, doch.
Ja, an einigen Stellen, aber den eigentlichen Systemfond nicht.
Na, der Fond ist der selber, aber du kannst den ja extrem filigran in seiner Dicke skalieren lassen.
Ja, okay, die Uhr ist dicker. Und außerdem haben sie in dieser Music App diese Überschriften so fett gemacht.
Sie gehen auf fetter. Also, sie hatten am Anfang so eine totale Filigralität.
Besonders in der Music App.
Und es konnte ihnen einfach nicht dünn genug sein, weil es halt einfach so unfassbar schick aussieht. Und mussten ja schon das Accessibility-Feature, fetter Text und so weiter hinzufügen. Und in gewisser Hinsicht, ich meine, am Anfang ist es immer erst mal so, oh Gott, ist es schon wieder anders, jetzt hab ich mich so gerade dran gewöhnt. Ich muss sagen, das war schon die richtige Antwort.
Also sie haben ja von 8 auf 9 den System von selber geändert, von Helvetica irgendwas, neue glaube ich, auf diesen neuen San Francisco. Aber ich glaube, den haben sie dann jetzt nicht noch mal im allgemeinen Gewicht geändert. Der ist glaube ich so geblieben erst mal.
Ja, der wird ja, du hast auch bestimmt diesen Typografie-Vortrag zu San Francisco gesehen, den sie auf der WWDC gezeigt haben.
Nee, ich bin dann doch kein Typografienerd.
Na das kann ich dir aber mal sehr empfehlen. Also das war wirklich einer der aufschlussreichsten...
Zur letzten WWDC?
Als sie San Francisco vorgestellt haben. Also jetzt nicht dieses Jahr, sondern...
Dann muss es wohl...
Vorletztes Jahr.
Ja, muss dann wahrscheinlich 2015 gewesen sein. Da war ja 9 schon drin.
Ich hab mich so mal wieder eingefallen, welches UI-Element ich noch ziemlich komisch finde und irgendwie immer daneben klicke. Der Snooze-Button bei der Alarmfunktion ist wunderschön groß, trifft man immer, aber den Ausbutton für den Wecker nicht.
Das ist natürlich Absicht.
Ey, boah, das geht mir so auf die Ketten morgens. Ich bin heute schon wieder fast ausgerastet.
Lass mich raten, das macht dich wach.
Naja, ich hab mindestens zwei Wecker, damit ich auch wirklich aufstehe.
Ja, das ist doch genau richtig für dich.
Da kannst du mir nicht außersindlich ausstehen.
Nee, wenn ich da drauf drücke, dann soll das beim ersten Mal funktionieren.
Du musst halt zielen.
Also der Link ist in den Show Notes. Da hab ich gerade den Chat geworfen, Introducing the new system for us. Und da erklären sie halt mal, was das Besondere an diesem San-Francisco-Font ist. Der ist halt jetzt nicht nur yet another font, sondern der ist halt als System-Font auf eine Art und Weise skalierbar und modifizierbar. Also du hast halt alle möglichen Optionen, erstmal so was die eigentliche Dicke betrifft. Und das Ding passt sich dann halt auch dynamisch an und geht dann eben auch sofort in so ein Headline-Format über. Also Headline-Fonts sind ja anders geschnitten als kleine Fonts. Also der mutiert sozusagen auch noch mit der Größe. Du sagst nicht nur, ich will dich jetzt größer haben und dann hast du dasselbe in 48 Punkten, was du vorher in 9 Punkten hast. Sondern der ist dann halt anders. Also der passt sich sozusagen der erforderlichen Optik an der Stelle an. Du kannst halt alle möglichen Sachen konfigurieren. Du kannst sagen, ich will jetzt Nullen, die als Null erkennbar und vom O unterscheidbar sind, haben. Also kriegst du dann sozusagen andere Zahlen oder möchtest du die 9, sodass der Strich unten wirklich rumgeht und nicht nur so schräg gerade runter geht. Es gab noch so diverse andere Kleinigkeiten. Also immer so auch diese Grenzen, wovon es manchmal in bestimmten Lagen anfangen, unpraktisch zu sein, weil sie eben genau in deiner speziellen Anwendung an der Stelle versagen, obwohl sie für viele andere dann eben gut funktionieren. Und das ist etwas, was sie bei diesem San-Francisco-Font halt gnadenlos durchgezogen haben. Du kannst halt auch stufenlos quasi die Dicke einstellen. Das ist ja genau dieses Feature, was so in iOS eben so drin ist. Das haben sie zwar mit Helvetica im Prinzip auch.
Ja, da haben sie schon angefangen mit.
Da haben sie schon mit angefangen, aber bei San Francisco ist das sozusagen Teil des, also der ganze Font ist um dieses konfigurierbare Wesen herum gebaut worden. Das fände ich schon ziemlich cool.
Nee, es ist nur so, wir hatten mit unserer App ja das Problem, dass der Designer gesagt hat, wir nehmen den Systemfont fertig. So, was macht Apple bei iOS 9? Macht einen neuen Systemfont. Und sprich, die App sieht komplett anders aus. Also jetzt fontmäßig unter iOS 8 wie unter iOS 9, was dazu geführt hat, dass wir sämtliche UI-Tests halt neu machen mussten, beziehungsweise die immer unter iOS 8 und unter iOS 9 laufen lassen mussten, weil die Laufweiten von den Fonts natürlich anders sind. Du musst dann immer gucken, passt der Scheiß noch rein, ist das Layout inordentlich und wie macht man UI-Tests? Üblicherweise, du machst halt Screenshots. Und wenn die Screenshots sich ändern, ist der Test rot. Das ist furchtbar, aber es geht nicht anders. Und das Ganze sieht jetzt aber so aus, als müssten wir das unter iOS 10 nicht machen, weil sich der Font als solcher erstmal nicht geändert hat.
Gab es nicht letztens bei dem Gruber irgendwie so ein Artikel auf irgendwie so eine, ja ich glaube auch eine Konferenz, so glaube ich sogar Apple, Microsoft und Google, ne und Adobe, genau, Apple, Microsoft und Adobe so ein neues Font-Format vorgestellt haben, wo genau das geht, was du gerade beschrieben hast. Also dass der Font-Designer nicht mehr sagt, das ist italic und das ist bold, sondern er gibt den ganzen Font ab und man kann halt an so Parametern drehen und dann wird er halt zu bold, aber es gibt also stufenlos sozusagen und der Designer sagt nur noch hier, das ist das bold, so wie ich mir das vorstelle, aber es ist halt nur noch eine Stufe und nicht jetzt speziell halt in bold abgeliefert, sondern das kannst du auch später dann dir noch weniger bold, mehr bold, mehr italic und so, also sozusagen du kriegst den kompletten dynamischen Font mit allen Features, die man so braucht, um das schön zu vergrößern, zu verkleinern und schräg zu stellen und so weiter. Ja, Vektor-Fonts haben wir jetzt ja auch schon, oder? Aber da sind dann wahrscheinlich die Beschreibungen auch drin, wie das halt mit dem bold, also wie das halt wachsen oder kleiner werden soll.
Ja, genau, was ich meine ist, dass du wirklich auch irgendwie einen Engel angeben könntest, für Atellic zu schieben.
Das war bei dem groben...
Open Type Variations in Open Type Version 1.8 ist halt Open Type. Also wir fangen jetzt nicht nochmal an, ein komplett neues Font-Framework zu machen deswegen, sondern Open Type in Version 1.8 kann auch sogenannte Font Variations und da sind dann eben so eine Sachen mit drin. Also es ist so diese ganze Multiple Master Fonts Geschichte, die war so die Vorlage bei Type 1 Fonts und das hat dann irgendwie alles zu Open Type geführt und Open Type Font Variations ist dann glaube ich dieses Feature, was du meinst.
Kann sein.
Das gibt es jetzt seit 14. September diesen Jahres, also mit anderen Worten seit zwei Wochen. Ja, müssen ja mitkommen, aber da ist dann der Abfilmer wieder zwei Jahre vorher schon lang geschlittert in diese Straße.
Nö, schon seit einer halben Stunde, glaube ich, nicht mehr eigentlich.
Na, wir müssen uns jetzt auch nicht zwingen. Nächstes Mal gibt es bestimmt neue Macbooks.
Toll, wenn ich nicht da bin.
Ich dachte, irgendjemand im Chat behauptete... 24.10.
Ah, gibt es einen Termin?
Würden die vorgestellt, ich weiß nicht, ob der schon offiziell ist, aber der wird wohl rumort.
Rumort bitte, das heißt, nächstes Mal gibt es immer noch keine Macbooks?
Wenn wir nicht einmal ausfallen lassen, nein.
Okay, aber wir wären am 26. dran. Dann können sie am 24. gerne einen neuen Macbook vorstellen. Dann müssen wir uns für die nächste Sendung noch was einfallen lassen.
Kriegen wir hin.
Brauchen wir neue Hobbies.
Am 26.
Hast du eigentlich mal dieses Jet Black jetzt in der Hand gehabt?
Nee. Ich hör nur Leute drüber reden. Ich war kurz im Apple Store und hatte überhaupt mal ein iPhone 7 in der Hand. Und es war...
Nicht Jet Black.
Nee, es war einfach nur so dieses Schwarz. Nein, ist das das normale. Sehe ich das richtig, dass hier niemand auf iPhone 7 wechseln will?
Nein, ich hab jetzt ein 6S von der Firma spendiert bekommen. Wenn ich jetzt ein 7 wollte, müsste ich es mir selber kaufen. Das ist mir dann doch nicht wert. Genauso wenig...
Du solltest es erst mal kaufen.
Mir das was wert ist, jetzt eine neue Apple Watch zu holen. Also irgendwie... Wasserdicht genug ist die alte, zum Duschen reicht's. Was ich extrem praktisch finde, weil morgens bin ich, was so Zeit anbelangt, immer so ein bisschen neben der Spur. Und gerade duschen, das tue ich dann doch auch gerne mal länger.
Du legst dir erst die Uhr an. Also egal wie dizzy du bist, du kriegst auf jeden Fall erst mal die Uhr an.
Genau. Und dann geh ich unter die Durche.
Und dann musst du duschen.
Genau, dann kann ich unter der Dusche immer auf die Uhr gucken, wie spät sie ist.
Kannst du mal die ersten Nachrichten lesen sozusagen.
Nee, das nicht, weil der Trick an der Uhr ist... Also ich weiß ja nicht, wie sie es bei Serious 2 gemacht haben, aber bei Serious 1, also Serious Zero, oder wie auch immer man sie nennen will. Da ist es so, wenn du mit der duschst, dann lösen die Tropfen auf der Uhr Touch-Events aus. Das heißt, wenn du das tatsächlich vorhast, mit der Uhr zu duschen, dann nimmst du sie kurz ab, sodass sie lockt. Oder machst du das Armband locker, sodass die Uhr lockt, und dann kannst du damit duschen, weil dann passiert nichts, wenn Touch-Events ausgelöst werden. Bevor ich morgens dusche, lege ich erst mal die Uhr an, so sieht es aus.
Auf jeden Fall habe ich das iPhone 7 kurz ausprobiert, zweimal mittlerweile, und muss feststellen, dass es ein, zwei Features gibt, was mir sehr zu sagt, extrem zu sagt.
Man kann auch damit duschen.
Der Button.
Warum?
So muss das sein. Also dieser mechanische Button war schon immer ein Problem, weil er ist einfach zu laut.
Zu laut, ja. Da habt ihr letztes Mal auch darüber geredet. Ich dachte, was?
Ja, der ist zu laut.
Ich kann das schon verstehen. Also zu laut. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich das zu lauten... Ja, vielleicht, wenn das so ein Kackgeräusch ist. Weil es gibt ja so einen schönen dumpfen... Weiß nicht, kann man halt nicht nachmachen. Aber wenn es einfach so ein tiefer Ton ist, den man auch nicht laut hört. Aber es gibt auch so ein lautes Knacken, so ein hochtoniges Klick und das nervt.
Ich will nicht in zu viele Details gehen, aber es gibt schon Momente, wo ich sehr schätze, dass es wirklich sehr leise ist, ich aber trotzdem ein gewisses Klickbedürfnis habe. Ich muss halt eine App wechseln. Das ist für mich wichtig. Als Nerd weiß ich, dass es für mich wichtig ist. Und ich weiß auch, dass Non-Nerds das in dem Moment unter Umständen nicht verstehen. Wenn ich einfach die Chance habe, diesen Vorgang durchzuführen, also mein Telefon zu benutzen, ohne dass es ein akustisches Signal sendet, das es jetzt gerade benutzt wird, sagen wir mal, es gibt keine optische Verbindung, nur eine akustische Verbindung. Innerhalb eines Raumes, der sehr leise ist. Du möchtest dein Telefon benutzen, aber es ist dir wichtig, dass nicht unbedingt jeder mitbekommt, dass du dein Telefon benutzt. Solche Situationen, und du kannst dir jetzt irgendwelche blumigen Bilder in deinem Hirn ausmalen, was für eine Situation das sein könnte.
Na, wie man schläft nebenan halt.
Ich gehe da jetzt nicht so ins Detail. Tatsache ist, das neue Telefon kannst du halt einfach klicken und du spürst es halt. Es ist nicht an derselben Stelle, das merkt man schon so, aber ist eigentlich auch total egal. Du kriegst die Rückmeldung, das ist das, was du brauchst. Und es klickt halt nicht blöd rum. Ansonsten brauch ich das jetzt erstmal nicht, weil ich hab definitiv ein Problem mit dem fehlenden Head-Control.
Ist das eigentlich bei iOS 10 neu, dass ich hier ganz doll klicken kann und zieh das so rüber? Ich geh links in die Mitte des Bildschirms, klick da ganz doll und zieh es einfach zur Seite.
Nein, das war bei 7 oder 9. Bei 9 war das schon. Bei 9 war das schon.
Das ist mir letztens aus Versehen passiert, hab ich noch nicht gewusst. Jetzt haben wir so Sachen, die hat man irgendwie verpasst.
Ja, seit es Force-Touch gibt.
Es funktioniert mit meiner Hülle nicht.
Du hast keinen Force-Touch. Das ist übrigens das, worüber man ordentlich ranten könnte. Als Linkshänder hat man ja das Telefon gerne in der linken Hand. Und dann funktionieren einfach verschiedene Gesten nicht richtig. Weil du...
Optimiert sind für die Hand rechts.
Genau, weil der Daumen bei der rechten Hand von rechts kommt.
Bei der Map zum Beispiel jetzt?
Nee, am schlimmsten ist es eigentlich bei normalen Table-Views, sprich bei Mehl. Wo du Mails mit so einem Swipe löschen willst.
Und der geht jetzt in die falsche Richtung, ja, verstehe.
Und du kannst es...
Aber gibt es nicht eine Einstellung für Links- oder Rechtshänder?
Ähm, nee, gibt es nicht. Es gibt in Accessibility jeden Scheiß, aber Rechtshänder gibt es halt nicht.
Dann schreib mal eine Mail! Also...
Das Ding ist, du kannst ja hier dieses Gelesen oder Archive, oder was auch immer du da einstellst, kannst du ja von links nach rechts swipen. Als Linkshänder swipest du aber tendenziell gerne vom Rand. Und wenn du aber links vom Rand swipest, dann gehst du halt zurück in die Navigations-Theorie. Das nervt mich tierisch. Da muss ich mal einen Bug schreiben irgendwann.
Schick ein Bild davon, dass du halt deinen rechten Arm nicht mehr hast, um das Problem gleich deutlich zu machen. Sonst verstehen die das ja nicht.
Ich hab den noch nie gehabt, ich bin Linkshänder.
Aber da sind sie doch immer sehr hinterher mit ihren Support für Links und Rechtshänder und Schrift von Links und Schrift von Rechts. Also das mögen sie doch, dass alles möglich ist, alles kann einfach. Und ich denke, das ist auch so eine Sache, haben sie einfach noch nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Ich glaube, das machen die gleich und sofort.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es so einfach zu lösen ist, das ist das Problem, aber... Nee, aber du musst halt, weißt du, mit dem rechten Daumen musst du halt einmal ganz rüber.
Du machst halt so und du willst das halt von der anderen Seite machen, das ist schon klar.
Genau, mit dem rechten Daumen musst du einmal ganz rüber, um das auszulösen. Aber mit dem linken, da bist du eh immer an der Stelle. Es ist irgendwie, naja, aber genug, da hab ich mein Point across bekommen. The end is nigh.
Genau, the end is nigh, weil wir wollen uns jetzt hier nicht von einem iOS 10-Detail zum nächsten hangeln. Oder? Was sagt Chewbacca dazu? Das dachte ich mir schon.
Vielleicht zu dem Thema noch. Ich krieg's jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht raus. Aber da gab's so ein schönes Video von jemanden, der eine Cola-Dose über den Tisch schiebt. Mit so einem Chewbacca-Bild drauf. Und die klingt auch noch wie Chewbacca.
Die Cola-Dose. Beim Schieben.
Das stimmt tatsächlich.
Hast du auch noch unseren Flash eigentlich?
unseren Flash?
Ja, haben wir schon so lange nicht mehr gehört.
Flash gibt's halt auch nicht mehr.
Ja, doch, Spiegel hat's ja drauf. Spiegel hat sich ja neu designed. Und die sind ja der Meinung, Flash müsste man ja doch irgendwie noch benutzen müssen. Was?
Da hat jemand die Cola-Dose gepostet.
Okay, dann spielen wir die Cola-Dose auch nochmal ab. Was Spiegel online hat.
Manche Videos da ist immer noch, dann kommt irgendwie, ja hier mach mal...
Dieser Spiegel-TV-Kram, der ist halt wahrscheinlich immer noch eul.
Ja, alles ist da eul. Vor allem hier mit diesem Spiegel Plus, wo das dann alles da in Krypto auf dem Bildschirm erscheint, hab ich schon erzählt, dass das eigentlich Rot-Minus-1 ist. So geil. Ich klicke immer oben auf den Reader-Mode, sodass man dann alles sehen kann, mach dann den ganzen Krypto-Zeugs, was man nicht lesen kann, in Buffer, google nach Rot13 online, paste das da rein, sag Rot25, weil das ist ja Minus-1 und schon geht das. Außer dass das Z halt nicht geht, weil das halt, also die rotieren halt nicht nur die Buchstaben, sondern den ganzen ASCII-Bereich, aber da kann man den halt lesen. Aber ja, ich glaub wir fehlen uns jetzt hier nur noch das...
Genau, wir fehlen uns nur noch. Also machen wir jetzt hier mal ein Ende. Ende mit Schrecken sozusagen, ne, Ende ohne Schrecken. Die Herren, die Dame. Wir verabschieden uns jetzt heute mal ein bisschen vorzeitig. Nächstes Mal gibt es wieder eine frische Sendung, da haben wir auch Themen. Ihr könnt uns zumindest auch Themen zuschicken, ihr könnt uns auch gerne was im Slack droppen und ihr könnt es auf Twitter schicken, ihr könnt euch alle möglichen Sachen einfallen lassen, aber heute nicht mehr.
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.